une production du studio sf
bio sans fil le podcast pour parce que
en
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce moment dans le boudoir qui est un os
3 espace disponible pour location au
studio sfr si vous avez un projet de
boîte car si vous avez un projet
d'entrevue si vous avez un projet de
livre audio de boys over de conférence
web de web séminaires de n'importe quoi
on se quitte la technique vous n'avez
qu'à penser à votre contenu et pourrait
tout est produit service clé en main la
technique le matériel quoi demander de
mieux allez au studio cirque concerts
puis cette semaine heureusement l'espoir
que vous êtes prêt à vous faire chic
mais
aujourd'hui on parle des physiques
pratique un gros sujet un sujet complexe
au sujet des fois mais qu'on est mal
compris mais compris on reçoit deux
chercheurs dans le domaine où william
dit chaque thème fort et et l'équipe
saint jean un grand plaisir
williams qui est plus dans la théorie et
philippe ledent l'expérimenté plus de
l'expérimentation
j'ai travaillé entre autres dans une
compagnie peau travaillé sur l'idée des
orateurs aquatique asterop on a parlé
beaucoup de qui sait que ça mange en
hiver la physique quantique c'est quoi
ce qu'est ce qu'on épuise y commence à
ce qu'ont pensé quoi les lois de la
nature de l'infiniment petit les attend
et que j'étais recréera super
passionnant commencent à se comporte
ce qu'on les règle jst qui régissent tu
sais si c'est une petite particule est
aussi c'est quoi l'éducation dans le
monde de tous les jours dans la bande à
nous comme ans après un plan c'est
comment qu'on utilise en tête
cette science à neutre notre bénéfice on
utilise de jeu de quelle manière et dans
le futur ça va être super super
intéressant ça peut changer le cours de
l'humanité peut-être donc c'était
vraiment super intéressant beaucoup de
notions dans son pas de danse physique
donc st paul à
propos des pêcheurs aller prendre une
marche questionné sur l'existence la vie
pierre venait d'être googlé de 3 terme
a+ mais vraiment bien compris je pense
que mr ce qui me passionne je pense que
vous allez messieurs pire encore si
elles sortaient par cas ce qu'ont fait
que vous pouvez
en même temps celui là je recommanderais
de l'écouté soit en voiture ou en ogm
sur le tapis roulant où est ce que votre
cerveau aux potes otage parce que
ce disque d'arcade mais c'est
extrêmement intéressant puisqu'elle
constitue en fait une bonne job de
filialisation des siliques rolls d'école
sans plus attendre les remercions que
monster puis a pas de coups en tout cas
le podcast de cette semaine et présenté
par paul ici oui à une compagnie qui
fabrique des matelas ici à montréal
c'est la saison des déménagements qui
s'en vient personnellement je déménage
et with équipes de la métropole retourna
belle ville de québec
et justement je change mon matelas parce
que mon matelas sacs à main ça part
vraiment longtemps gelé pis des matelas
ça peut prendre plusieurs voies sont
propres goy en bactéries en acariens
c'est le temps de 10 cartes et mon
matelas et pour ce faire je vais prendre
un matelas police ni surtout avec leur
politique de 5,2 gratuit premièrement
police lit avant toute chose it off la
livraison gratuite avec sa série glee on
s'attable slim ahmad le c'est lourd
c'est gros
déménager à battle sera conduite pas des
ménages y sont inclus je t'aime mon mac
lui un policier va t'amener cédric jégou
deuxième acte s'ennuie des cff veulent
essayer de revenir dessus à masquer ses
positions sur deux vantaux côté que si
jamais après 99 me après 109 et dépôts
content c'est pas ton goût bah tu peux
retourner gratuitement fillon d'autres
questions qui cédait 8 mai
ça va pas enlever parce qu'elles sont
incroyables mattler qui irait ne
cherchiez vous quittez les gars là que
sinon on a 1 95 ou des amis c est quelqu
un a majuscule en un mot est-il 3ds un
film ça me donne 25 pour sa de radés
présent contre ce qu'elle considère à
d'accor s'y colle tellement
considérables que je constate
mais je vais considérer tous ces
problèmes j'ai construit si koessler
allez sur le lien dans la description du
pot 4 0 code promo est passé les
meilleurs du sommeil de toute votre
le podcast de cette semaine et présenté
par nos amis chez monsieur
mais
honnêtement on vit des meilleurs boxeurs
ont créé les meilleurs boxeurs qu'il m'a
été donné de portée de ses boxeurs leur
jeu les ici c'est les brief de
m'indiquer puis qui viennent nos
auditions les en or mais ils viennent
aussi avec des couleurs des motifs
maintenant moi je dors avec ses bas sur
le à toutes les nuits piller pas une
fois que quand je viens pour les maîtres
après on change en outre certaines
radios fronton où est-ce que j'ai pas
ces cas ça fait 16 ans que tu viens pour
mettre un gilet ou quelque chose que tu
es contente et à chaque fois que tu lui
donnes penser à quel point des comptes
en demie je pense que c'est ce que je
voudrais ben ouais ça me fait ça avec
les vaccins à masquer pas chaque fois
que je touchais dingue mais je mets mes
bases à chaque fois je ne pensais d'eux
comme axe angry birds
ça s'est fait par mois d'autres choses
demain skype accueillons pas la france
ce seuil on dit joies de la vie voir des
choses qui fait que même si ce téléphone
2 oui
même en skate ils font plein de produits
shampoings
gels fond du parfum ils font des réseaux
électriques table la mort 4.0 et ward
preuve il va excessivement bien et est
conçu à la base pour
la gestion de votre pilosité de vos
bijoux tamim défaut d'utiliser ce que
vous voulez c'est vraiment il va
vraiment bien moi c'est de loin dans
électrique qui veulent mieux s'accroche
pour trèbes où il est soigné c'est comme
si tu goûtes klein un coup une fois
réglé c'est vraiment les vendredis on
les aime il supporte les sports - quelle
est la dernière renouvelables ce même
partenariat avec avec minsk donne
vraiment des fidèles partenaires safin
podcasts et du studio sfr on un code
promo pour l'eau depuis l'a4 avons
encore tous les codes promo qu'on vous
donne sont pas cheap en partie parce que
c'est parce que m et avec le code promo
sans filtre en un mot vous avez 20 %
rabais et le shipping gratuit pour vrai
alors dépôts non négligeable non mais
bon sang c'est un 25e salon le mettre en
action sinon négligence mais aussi même
script serait là dessus percy kemp ce
stade est déjà beaucoup trop lent et a
gravement blessé à la conversation banco
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
wright c'est parti salut les gars siècle
bonjour cela passait vraiment une belle
initiative de invité aujourd'hui merci
d'avoir accepté l'invitation gros sujet
aujourd'hui les ouais c'est probablement
des sujets les plus
mais compris et point dessus qu'on va
avoir eu à date opatija c'est qu'on
n'est pas content le chantier a fort à
un disclaimer à nos auditeurs mois pour
le bien de la conversation je vais jouer
vraiment ligne c'est pas du tout parce
que je comprends rien du tout de ce dont
on va parler mais je vais jouer le rôle
de la personne contre absolument
[Rires]
première main pour les gens qui nous
écoutent qui ont qu'une des deux ce qui
est la mécanique quantique la physique
quantique ou quanti premièrement la
musique romantique mais je penche pour
une préférence de personnes moi j'ai
toujours dit quantique puis je sais pas
d'où ça vient ok mais quand on a deux
des personnes qui prônent le coin sait
de quoi on voyait avec le cantique
pourra partir maintenant fait que rien
que si aucune des séquelles faites-nous
mini base pour commencer à construire
tranquillement le château de cartes que
sur cette conversation le
jeu peut commencer postiers en fait la
physique quantique c'est une théorie la
plus précise pour comprendre le monde
qui nous entoure
j'ai fixé moi je le vois un peu comme un
des beaux accomplissements l'humanité
mais c'est vraiment un effort collectif
ça des prix des millénaires concerne la
féclaz la physique quantique ça répond
deux questions de ce monde au premier en
moins de quoi sommes nous faits ou le
monde est fait c'est que les ingrédients
qu'on regarde vraiment un morceau de
bois puis on joue on était l'homme le
plus passé le plus possible puis
deuxièmement comment ce qu'ils
comportent ces ingrédients là c'est
comme des balles de bière ou un ballon
de sa crème la réponse est non fait que
ça remonte un peu même à la grèce
antique parce que diffuseur figuraient
que sa demande ait de quoi est faite la
matière
aristote
qui est souvent lui quand qu'on aime
moins parce qu'il attend plusieurs
points il pensait que la matière c'était
à continue fait que c'était fait
d'éléments continue l'eau la terre le
feu
et peu importe comment tout court quant
aux objets tunis tu peux toujours le
coupé plus de tournées les plus petits a
pas de limite est pas quelque chose tu
arrives
c'est l'ingrédient ellis paie plein pied
y est contre ou de la scop le bois
milieu plus de beau scoop tour se boit
encore et encore du bois puis 10 est par
définition
pas entièrement temps sur certains
points c'est l'un qui nous hante on se
comporte comme ça mais un autre de ses
collègues démocrates lui avait une
vision que la matière quand tu regarde
vraiment de près et fait d'éléments
indivisible indestructible qui a appelé
à tomasz et aujourd'hui on a le mot
attendent qu'il a d'ailleurs
fait savoir qu'il y avait plus eu raison
car histoire au final je sais il se
basait sur une sur l'intuition parce
qu'au final les verriers pour mesurer
aux pauvres c'était plus nu une exercice
de pensée des drames moi je pense que c
est indivisible au final on peut pas
savoir ce serait un grand pas de
l'infiniment petit de ses six points
fini mmm est très petit il se base sur
les connaissances qu'ils avaient de tous
les genres et les grains de sable sur
une plage des choses comme ça mais en
effet c'est pas si peu adéquat parce
qu'il ya jamais eu accès à ces échelles
saloperies 2001 au moins pour que
l'humanité a les outils pour regarder de
près puis voir que des choses discrète
qui se cache sous ce qu'est l'art
continue-t-il à bois ou les métaux des
leurs
[Musique]
je pense une expérience vraiment qu'ils
facile à comprendre qui est un peu donné
raison à démocrite c'est
l'expérience ou ce qu'ils avaient des
grains de pollen sur de l'eau puis à
cette époque là c'était la
neuvième siècle et des microscopes qui
était assez performant et qu'on pouvait
revoir à ses proches qui relèguerait le
pollen qui voyait qu'il grains de pollen
était ticket com part des choses
invisibles se promenait comme ballotté
dans l'eau maintenant lotus à leur
uniforme fait qu'est ce qui fait qu'il
fait pas le thé comme ça qui de gauche à
droite de manière régulière avec les
scientifiques de l'époque on conjecturer
que c'est des molécules ou attendre dans
le liquide dans l'eau qui viennent
piquer le lire une petit bougé entre
elles puis qui bouge à l'écran pauline
c'est ça il n'y avait pas accès aux
attentes parce que le microscope et de
passer plus un mais ils ont dit que de
sa bouche comme ça ça ressemble faisait
tiquer par des plus petites billes c'est
une déduction ouais c'est une déduction
de l'expérience sais pas si c'est pour
voir des tripotées mesurer sa a été
pensée théorisé finalement c'est ça puis
plusieurs années après donc début xxème
siècle en fait un physique et travailler
à meggen pour une période
difficile
son nom à son nom et médias mais le
physique le feu a pris un faisceau
radioactifs un gaz radioactif puis le
lancer sur une mince feuille d'or
puis s'est rendu compte que si tout ceux
des fois la messe
[Rires]
à l'époque qu'ils savaient même pas
tellement les conséquences dangereuses
manipulation si librement mais bref il
lancé soeur comme il bombarder la
feuille d'or puis se rendre compte que
la plupart des particules du faisceau
passer au travers comme si terry mais
quelques jeunes y revenons en pleine
face donc avec ces observations là il
conclut que la matière c'est l'homme
s'est fait principalement de vide sinon
le faisceau parce que j'aime mon travail
c'était quelque chose comme
[Musique]
ces particules dépenses au travers
principalement mais des fois il frappe
quelque chose de vraiment ans dans ce
petit cirque bondissent fait que lui
bâtie l'image du premier à tomber avec
ça image expérimental c'est que le
modèle planétaire et un noyau très très
petit mais très lourd comme le soleil
puis autour et des petites charges
électriques négative qu'on appelle les
électrons qui orbite
puis le noyau positif et globalement et
seppois électrique la tombe neutre les
petits électrons les planètes d'une
balance et la change du noyau le soleil
fait que l'on se rapproche la vraie
image de l'at on sait pas si simple que
le soleil des planètes parce que
physique quantique en fuite comme telle
et va en parler un peu les lois sont
différentes des doigts de tirer des
planètes s'applique pas aux seychelles
qu'on peut pas dire qu'un électron c'est
comme une planète qui orbite autour du
soleil mais déjà ce une image qui quand
même
qu'ils portent assez loin il s'est quand
même permis aux physiciens scientifique
de déjà avancé beaucoup mais si on était
capable de zoomer un milliard de fois on
verrait pas sûr finalement c'est pour
çà a pas de la dette ici pour qu'on peut
se concevoir dans notre esprit mais ça
peut vraiment se souvenant de ce qu'est
ce que tu as à l'air de ça
est
ce que est ce que ça si on avait des
instruments entre est capable de voir ce
outre complètement trouvez vous la
question ou si haut si c'est plus
un espèce de modèles théoriques on
imagine con
con qu'on décide de mettre en images
comme ça parce que le cerveau plus comme
tu l'as tu veux dire comme comme l'image
d'un bâton qu'on voit si tu n'as qu'à
tombe sur google
se serait on verrait pas sans
savoir que les électrons en fait c'est
pas des planètes en fait il ya même pas
de position bien défini c'est un peu
malade parce que quand tu penses tout
objet une position mais définitivement
affectés l'an un électron c'est pas
comme ça pour dire qu'il est définitive
at il définitivement sa position là il
pourrait un peu n'importe où dans la
pièce fait qu'une image qui plus
réalise un attentes c'est ce qu'on voit
qu'on fait des mesures du microscope
très précis microscope électronique
on voit que l'ecc transcom un nuage
autour de la tombe avec des formes
particulières qu'on peut comprendre que
la physique quantique mais c'est pas une
planète a une position définie c'est
plus comme si on le mesure on peut le
trouver là où le trouver à plusieurs
endroits en même temps quand même pas
parce que tu es une mesure au moment
précis où est ce que tu fais la mesure
tulard est dans le temps c'est ça mais
c'est sûr fait le même système ce
prix-là tongs préparer manière identique
hydrogène par exemple sur fait la même
mesure sur le mesure ayant des limites
du moment c'est une mesure poppy ses
soucis je disais que jadis j'écoutais du
grès ou des physiques ainsi qu'un maman
dormait on avait statué sur coup en tic
cointe excuses et que finalement avant
qu'on fasse la mesure des quelque chose
mettons
l'électron existe en possibilités
finalement en pourcentage il peut être
un petit peu un petit peu le petit
moment qu'on le regarde lui devient
physique mais avant ce métier que je
pense que c'est important de vraiment
clarifier ce point la commission veut
c'est un fondement dit d'importantes
bien comprendre ouais cet aspect là puis
comme comme william le disait psy tout à
fait juste c'est un des grands sur une
des grandes révélations de ses premières
expériences là c'était non seulement on
a vu ces particules indivisible là qu'on
appelait des atomes hausse des attentes
mais on a vu comment ils se comportaient
et on s'est rendu compte que les lois de
la nature les lois que isaac newton
avait défini pour j'ai un ballon je
lance je le vois évoluer puis capable de
calculer sa trajectoire donc la gravité
et puis c'est vrai qu'il a vite et f
égale est molle ce qu'on faisait au
secondaire 1 action réaction ces choses
là ça s'applique plus aussi facilement
parce qu'on ait pu les mêmes objets pis
c'est illogique d'une certaine façon
parce que toute notre vie on a vécu avec
des objets qui nous entourent qui se
comporte comme ça des choses qu'on
observe le dessus c'est la seule chose
qu'on observe dans notre vie c'est des
choses qui se comporte comme ça c'est la
première fois que l'humanité voyez
quelque chose qui se comportait pas
comme ça fuck you cette de loi de la
nature la loi des deux nous les astres
solis grosse affaire pieds les lois de
cette affaire les atomes et compagnie et
ce qui est un pas ou exact puisque est
important de dire c'est que quand on
voit ces particules depuis petit lob
victime dit quand j'en parlais moins
dans ma famille dans des super de
famille les gens ont souvent
l'impression qu'on parle de particules
élémentaires ou d'électrons d'atomes que
c'est des petits grains de sable
éventuellement ou des petites billes ou
quelque chose ils disent à quoi ça
ressemble qu'on le voit c'est exactement
la question à quoi ça ressemble
physiquement si si j'étais capable de le
voir imaginer à quoi ça ressemble est ce
que j'ai un petit grain de sable fibré
mais en réalité ce que les gens se
rendit compte six sexy plutôt un nuage
c'est ça se compare plus à un son une
vague
est donc la même façon que quand tu fais
une sieste une corde de guitare ça sert
à rien de dire qu'elle est au début de
l'accord doit la fin de l'accord
d'association et tout le long de la côte
ces particules à électrons par exemple
qui piégé par un par un noyau bail il
est décrit par intel ont depuis londres
elle est partout partout autour n'est
convié mesurer et c'est ça qui est
vraiment particulière mécanique
quantique quand je regarde une corde de
guitare ou quand je regarde une vague
dans le silence et des ombres quand je
les regarde les et son fils est
complètement passifs comme procédé moi
quand je regarde long elle ne sait pas
que je la regarde bien continuer à vivre
sa vie comme si comme si de rien n'était
en mécanique quantique c'est le
contraire
regardez un objet de mesurer c'est
catastrophique on est un processus actif
à partir du moment où on veut regarder
quelques bâtiments où on voit quelque
chose cette chose là body fier et quand
je vois mon ombre aux électrons qui a si
tu peux pas imaginer là comme vous
voulez la scène du tissu qui vibre c'est
une corde qui décide c'est quelque chose
dans l'espace qui peuvent m'aider que
vous ne mesurez vous venez de le
concentrer en un seul endroit et
notamment y voir évoluer votre formule 1
mais chaque fois que vous avez mesuré
il va s'agir il va s'arrêter
momentanément en position ou en énergie
sa fréquence à quelle fréquence reste
ici je mesure la fréquence très très
précisément au début c'est comme un
conte faim sont à cannes qui tente de
faire plein note en même temps sur la
même cote parce que si je sens très bien
je parle de jours notre pure mais s'ils
sont très mal au pape les notes même
temps puis vous me direz mais la
fréquence à quelles mesures peuvent tout
d'un coup chante très bien parce que le
son s'est écrasé un seul de ses
fréquents donc c'est ça aussi la magie
c'est de voir ces objets là mais de voir
que leur comportement absolument rien à
voir avec avec lui tous les autres
objets que tous les autres êtres humains
avaient vu dans
ces ceux qui comme le mans contre
intuitif pour notre notre instinct de ce
qu'on connaît de la vie parce que si je
regarde la roche alors je sans fouler
leur garde mais quand qu'on arrive à ce
moment là qu'il ya dessus est ce qu'on
connaît là la raison pourquoi ça se
comportent de même où ceux ci il ya
plusieurs théories pions on peut pas
l'expliquer
pense la réponse rapide sinon ouais
des questions philosophiques en fait la
fusée moi c'est si ces cendres est que
quelques mois il ya en préparant pour la
conversation je réalisais c'était comme
on dit à quelqu'un c'est beaucoup dans
la philosophie est ce qu'on explique
parce que c'est pas quelque chose qu'on
sait plus que les 9 10 ans parce qu'on
l'ait vraiment mesuré on a un rôle c'est
ça on l'a vu lui même on utilise
aujourd'hui dans des dispositifs plus ou
moins parler tout à leur interprétation
de ce qu'on mesure effective qu on met
des mots sur les phénomènes on
interprète qui est des écoles de pensée
en bout de ligne les mêmes mesures que
tu ferais mais tu pense différemment
conceptuellement parlant
la différence la clause ific la physique
c'est que des équations qui prédisent
des résultats puis après tu peux les
mesures est une expérience que ce soit à
montréal à copenhague titre la même
enfance qui nous ouvre bien mais ça
avance à vienne 2 août qui a commandé ce
à la physique quantique comme einstein
la demande y est demandé de manière
rhétorique le quai commander salatic et
dieu joue aux dés
on sait pas vraiment ce qu'on a du coup
voilà expérimental
mais comme des williams un des plus
grands accomplissements parce qu'on sait
comment les choses se passent avec une
grande grande grande précision
c'est la théorie qui qui la plus précise
pour savoir comment les choses se
passent non c'est pas pourquoi elle se
passe comme ça il y encore des questions
ouvertes sa démarche philosophique parce
que il va falloir trouver des façons de
répondre à ces questions lopy ben il ya
des gens qui s'intéressent vraiment à
fabriquer des objets et les observer qu'
voir essayer de les mesurer pendant que
pendant qu'ils se font pendant que
londres de ses fondements dans la mesure
la regarder vraiment physique stacy
motive et déjà à vienne sont en train de
faire
des particules de plus en plus grosses
qui ont un comportement chaotique et
pour être capable d aube d observer
exactement plus facilement exactement
des débits de verre qui font tenir dans
le vide avec des avec des méthodes à
lévitation optique et y regarde
vite et sans complexe qui requiert pour
les aborder des
dvd des méthodes expérimentales
extrêmement sophistiqué donc mon à 7 bis
de valeur on la voit elle aussi non
vraiment ils ont baissé de la mesure et
pour voir comment est-ce que ça se
produit pour ainsi commencé de compte
avoir des hypothèses pour répondre à la
question du pourquoi parce que le
commencer
mais pourquoi
ceci notamment ceux ci comme un peu même
des fois plus la physique si la même
théorie la même équation prédit le même
résultat physique mais différentes
manières d'y penser en tant que
physicien s'est choisie elle que tu veux
ouais mais ce qui compte c'est que tes
prédictions
soit validée par l'expérience même si
c'est bon mais des gens qui se penche
là-dessus puis une question plus
philosophique
une rotation qui vous il faut comprendre
qui était la physique ce jour en flux lé
6 mécanique on sait que c'est pas dieu
qui est venu qui écrit les lois sur une
feuille de paypal si l'humain qui
conceptualise et que ce que la physique
quantique c'est la vérité finale
sûrement parce qu'il ya un horizon
concis que des problèmes en détention
avec le courant tic c'est qu'on parle de
gravité des combinés gravité les forces
qui tentent des armes et d'autres objets
comme la terre et le cantique on
n'arrive pas à avoir une théorie
quantique la gravité n'arrive pas à
réconcilier finalement les les les deux
les deux sets de l'oil finalement qu'on
va parler plus tôt c'est comme si tu y
mettons le film de terry avait hérité
cesser d'essayer de trouver ça c'est
précisément ça qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce
qui relie les deux parce qu'il sait quoi
les en fait les conflits qu est ce qui
fait qu elle fonctionne pas avec l'autre
c'est une bonne question
écoute la manière 5 je suis préparé pour
ça mais de manière simple c'est que
c'était c'est de la gravité plagron
coantic il s'avère que mathématiquement
tout devient fini de différence fait qu
tarifs pas avoir des équations qui se
tiennent debout
littéralement
littéralement c'est ça tu as fait
c'est vrai que c'est trois dimensions
spatiales puis face à ça marche pas les
déficits qui ont été un peu plus
créatifs puis ont pu aussi ces trois
gravité trois dimensions spatiales
puisses tu penses aux particules comme
les points particuliers pas de forme
comme électron c'est le nuage en bout de
ligne c'est pas une forme la particule
passe-t-il mesure c'est très proche d'un
point bas tu trouveras pas qu'une forme
particulière
c'est quand même ponctué la dualité
ondes particules électrons lundi même si
non tu mesures près d'un point ça reste
que c'est localisé près du point c'est
ponctuel comme objet complexe comporte
comme les deux si on le regarde ou non
vraiment c'est ça ce soit mais tu le
regardes cesse comporte comme un peu
comme un point mais déjà enterré des
cordes qui sont dites en a peut-être que
c'est pas des points tight que
l'électron se regarde vraiment très très
très proche distance qu'on n'arrive pas
sondé aujourd'hui être un objet comme
une bande élastique
une petite corne en anglais swing
la série big bang theory chers jeunes je
pense intéressant des cordes
le tri des cornes c'est une des tueries
qui propose deux alliés contre ceux qui
gravitent et il ya un prix à payer
c'est en dix ou onze dimensions
d'espace-temps neuf ou dix dimensions
puis en même temps les objets deviennent
des petites corps mais on n'a jamais vu
que les électrons d'autres persécutions
des cornes s'est dit très petite échelle
là donc c'est pas mal hypothétique quand
même c'est une structure qui existe
c'est juste que il ya un prix à payer le
téléphone et je lui dirai tout plein
d'autres questions ils n'ont répondu
exact et qu'on n'a pas la réponse encore
aujourd'hui le tour des cornes c'est un
des candidats sûrement la plus populaire
pour unifier gravité et le reste des
forces y compris la coincer gouverner
différence mais c'est pour une question
qui finalise et parce que en laboratoire
c'est très dur l'attesté pas c'est rare
qu'on a besoin la théorie quantique la
gravité les régimes dans lequel on a
besoin vraiment c'est près d'un trou
noir dans lequel la matière est
tellement dense que la force de gravité
et à ses formes en penser les autres
forces parce qu'on nous là on est assise
à table on sent pas la gravité on nous
donne de l'autre on a tellement fait des
fois qu'on attaque
[Rires]
les trottoirs pour les observer c'est
tellement loin que nos outils sont
toujours et directes souvent une photo
du trou noir dans ce n'est pas l'acte et
qui a été sorti la tête la première donc
c'est pour montrer à quel point si des
objets qui sont 4,5 petit pixel si c'est
peu mais c'est très petit comme objet
assez compact un trou noir c'est petit
c'est extrêmement petit extrêmement
immersif ces lots mais c'est extrêmement
compacte s'était tu prends la masse du
soleil je produis chefs exacts la main
comme dans la taille de la montréal et
le soleil éclatant ses danses c'est
extrêmement dense mais c'est petit si
compare souvent top 6 la
ccc
mais comme disait william la matière est
faite pratique principalement de vide
avoir été appelé une place pour écraser
la maintiens suis pour les filaments
fort sur ce thème des choses sur moi
j'ai fait avant de me diriger en
littérature j'ai fait chimie physique en
sont leurs cinq ans salut celle du monde
le professeur de chimie et de physique
nemo quelqu'un qu'on parlait de ce puits
de la matière puis il y avait vraiment
un genre de bloc hier intellectuelle
afin que mais pourquoi ma main passe pas
à travers la table comprend pas pourquoi
tu sais si si la matière est faite de
vide principalement c'était dans quelque
chose qui était qui est encore
aujourd'hui dur pour moi de 2 comme
comprendre nous de rationaliser on
dirait
mais j'ai pas vraiment question
parce que je suis pas le seul à se dire
ok d'alphonse il avait fait de vide
majoritairement what's up avec la table
c'est des questions qu'on sait qu'ils
reviennent souvent puis pourquoi je peux
voir à travers une vitre n'est pas à
travers une une table
là je dirais que on expérimente pas
beaucoup de force dans notre vie on
expérimente la gravité et l'autre force
qu'on a quatre grandes forces dans la
nature puis il ya ne sait lequel garde
mais ton juste pour leurs bêtes à la
gravité de la force électromagnétique
non l'électricité plutôt des fautes deux
forces nucléaires que c'est seulement
les deux premières expériences
au jour le jour qui servent à exprimer
ex expliqué la majorité de ce que nous
on expérimente expérimentés comme être
mais à moins de vous fabriquer des
bombes nucléaires dont vous avez besoin
de
soleil
classe comme grosse entrée c'est quand
même une grosse centrale nuclaire
exactement une centrale qui existent
pourtant pour cela la fusion des fusions
de 7 à la fission parce que le soleil de
bain de la gravité ils ont fait qu'il
peut compact et des noyaux puis en forme
et d'autre ses relances d'énergie sur
terre on essaie de farce en laboratoire
pouvant site efficace pour remplacer
d'autres sources d'énergie y compris la
fission mais on n'est pas encore rendu à
voir la fusion efficace ça prend comme
des gros gros gros laser pour compacter
les médecins c'est autant d'énergie
qu'il en ressort c'est ainsi ce jour
pour l'instant mais si on revient à la
table donc ce que je disais il ya
clairement pas la gravité qui joue un
rôle donc c'est les forces électriques
les forces électriques explique je
dirais 99 % quand on se pose des
questions pourquoi mais je peux voir à
travers la fenêtre pourquoi non et ainsi
que c'est que c'est ces particules
élémentaires ca tombe là comment est-ce
qu'ils ont une cohésion entre eux c'est
qu'ils ont une force électrique et la
force électrique elle et des milliards
et des milliards de fois plus forte que
la force de gravité gravitationnelle
donc oui j'ai l'impression que c'est
raide que je suis présent ici j'essaie
de sauter je ne veux pas être est moins
loin parce que la gravité c'est fort
imaginez-vous des milliards et des
milliards de fois plus fort la force
électrique qui re qui gardent les atomes
ensemble les électrons avec les attendre
un atom avec un autre donc tout ce qui
est chimiste et si justement échanger
ses actes rôle avec des forces
électriques va quand j'essaie de passer
ma main à travers la table mais il faut
qu'il faudrait que je sais par des
milliards des bâtons qui eux mêmes sont
ces puces sont servis par des forces qui
sont des milliards de fois plus forte
que la grève des facs ou ea sports sport
tu vas y arriver
mais il
oui mais il ya des attentes qui sont
moins bien que les autres accès sûr que
des fois c'est un petit faiblesse dans
ton matériaux oui c'est vrai que dans
une fenêtre des fois son frère vraiment
dans un point ponctuelle on peut mettre
beaucoup de force puis on peut y arriver
et puis vous êtes déjà vu quelque chose
de cassé
mais en gros c'est quand même beaucoup
plus grosse énergie que ça prend quête
pour sauter larmes puis est ce que
j'imagine que de se séparer des attentes
c'est quelque chose qui peut se faire si
ce qu'on appelle toutes les réactions
chimiques - les réactions chimiques
s'est gardé les attendent on a un paquet
on en a une centaine la saison toutes
classes notamment période où les
fondamentaux comment les agences on
fabrique des molécules et qui ont laissé
par pour former d'autres maillots ce
qu'on appelle des réactions je suis
quand je brûle la table je pars avec des
molécules de bois je veux pas trop
m'avancer sur ce qui est là dedans là
mais éventuellement je faire d'autres
molécules aux fans du charbon je referme
le dj du co2 dioxyde de carbone soit
prendre des objets donc on va
transformer mais je change jamais mais
met à tomber noyau mais noah du reste
toujours les mêmes
et voilà si si je veux faire briser mes
attentes et ce qu'on appelle faire la
direction déclare ce qu'on fait dans des
réacteurs nucléaires pour faire ou ce
qu'on fait dans des bombes atomiques par
exemple on prend des attentes très très
gros souvent comme la vision qu'ont les
casses paul et paul a pas deux attendent
qu'on sépare en deux un à temps
comprendre un noyau qui on le casse en
deux tous écrits d'énergie
dégage énormément d'énergie mais ça
prend beaucoup d'énergie pour le faire
donc mais si tu commences le processus
puis qui contrôlent pas la réaction ça
peut s'emballer puis comme adjoint monde
il sait plus faire sans balle pour vraie
sagesse et s emballe pour des années
aussi c'est très dur à arrêter une fois
que c'est parti fixe une réaction qui
est on arrive à faire de manière
contrôlée aujourd'hui puis on à
l'énergie pour la commencer après le
défi suivant c'est la contrôler la
vision nocturne puissant a fait une
belle application de physique ont cédé
première l'application qui est jamais de
la mécanique quantique est vraiment une
des grosses le parce qu'avant on avait
pas d'énergie nucléaire est dépassé les
gens dans la guerre nos clients un
matisse était plus dommageable qu'autre
chose mais les gens ont compris ma
structure des attentes puis des noyaux
après puis là avec soyons plus beau des
réacteurs à fission ce dérivé de scie
durant la deuxième guerre mondiale pam a
avec aussi le dancing killing clairement
quelque chose que einstein a milité
contre lui et contribuer à cela mais ben
ali des allergies nucléaire malaisie
sont un mal parce que ça nous avait créé
un monstre littéraire qui aujourd'hui
ont le spectre est humain est de retour
un peu avec ce qu'on voit dans le monde
en europe et en russie mais bref en
comprenant la physique quantique on a pu
contrôler la fission nucléaire puis
extraire l'énergie chauffer de l'eau
avec kinect on au shout for des turbines
tous les deux turbines institué comme
fer qu'il doit électricité holiday et la
gravité fait couler un coin cours d'eau
fait couler l'eau ben là tu fais
chauffer de l'eau ça fait tourner une
turbine puis entendait que ça redevient
une solution à la mode le présentement
la lumière parce que tu dis catastrophe
que je pense a été un peu démoniser mais
finale au final c'est quand à moins
d'accidents et qu une solution
écologique moi j'ai travaillé quatre
heures de en france c'est un gros débat
c'est un immense débat
en allemagne s'est retiré après
fukushima 2 2 il faut commencer à faire
mais vraiment toutes leurs centrales
nucléaires ils ont des dépendances à
d'autres sources d'énergie qui des fois
ça mais oui effectivement parce qu'on
veut d'aider des sources d'énergie qui
met des décarbonés qui met pas de
gaz carbonique il y en a pas infiniment
donc soit qu'on va avec des panneaux
solaires des éoliennes des choses comme
ça où des centrales nucléaires quand on
sait qu il fonctionne très très très
efficacement mais une fois que notre
combustible aient pu tellement utile on
peut plus l'utiliser pour retirer
d'énergie faut il faut le sortir puis
changer de combustible mais le
combustible puis bon il est encore
dangereux
qu'est ce qu'on fait
nucléaire
6 puis assez bon pour pour être pour une
centrale mais c'est suffisamment
dangereux pour compte
non mais les gens
ont
été proposés la gravité jal était
proposée pour les bains pour la wii no
say ce serait la mère parce que la série
voire détruit toutes les attentes metz
mais c'est des coups ce sens qu'ils sont
ils réels incroyable que ça ça a juste
été discuté
la prochaine étape une fois conduit les
débats
jamais
on en voit ce lapin puis on ne peut plus
accepter une des premières applications
mais au delà d'une théorie c'est des
applications les génériques dont les
ingénieurs nucléaires y apprendre des
gimmicks la faction à polytechnique mais
aujourd'hui encore les la mécanique
quantique est utilisé pour d'autres des
applications qui commence à vraiment
émergé depuis depuis je peux dire des
c'est toujours quand est-ce que ça a
commencé deux années 60 70 les gens ont
commencé à dire comment est ce qu'on
pourrait utiliser d'autres effets
par exemple william est quand même un
des principaux intérêts de recherche
c'est de fabriquer des matériaux mais de
les fabriquer mais les imagine les
théories des les matières des théorisé
des matériaux dans lesquelles les les
électrons se comporte de façon à dicter
pas là mais quand tu peux en parler
seulement huit mois mais c'est vers là
qu'est ce qu'une application si sexy
[Rires]
pour le québec qu'on ait des grands
producteurs d'électricité manipulation
qui nous parle
c'est la supraconductivité
je me suis dit qu'est michel dumont
notre prof secondaire et avait parlé lui
avait dit si on trouve une matière qui
conduit parfaitement électricité on peut
alimenter n'importe quoi avec des
quantités
minimes d'actrice tellement c'est ça
parce que hydro l'un présentement aux
produits frits cité principalement au
nord dans les grands barrages
électriques baie james et chez terrain
il faut l'amener jusqu'à montréal dans
la région ou plus loin si on me fournit
aux états unis voilà maintenant exporter
mais le problème c'est qu'il ya beaucoup
de pères dans le transport à cause de la
résistance électrique on estime ses
pertes la combine pourcentage de
l'énergie cre émeutes on sait si c'est
compliqué puis ça dépend des
architectures du réseau quant à calais
quand l on parle on est à 7 135 mille
vols justement pour réduire au maximum
ses je pourrais pas de neige chez moi
c'est quoi les pertes le petit massif
quand même ses majorettes additionne
toutes les pertes dans tout les fils
c'est de nos maisons aussi parce
qu'après des pertes aussi chez vous
c'est d'immenses
bon et du moins là mitigé on transporte
des très hauts voltages terrain mais
quand ça rentre dans ta maison n'ont
réduit du volcan
mais si on pouvait remplacer tous les
fils de cuivre aluminium peint des
matériaux supraconducteurs qui eux n'ont
aucune résistance électrique il pas de
perte en courant électrique
on souffrait beaucoup le challenge
secure les supraconducteurs en général
ça se produit très proche du zéro absolu
zéro absolu si la température la plus
froide complète
pour marc mon cours des
de physique sont leurs 5 - 273
degrés kelvin celle chaussures 6,0 des
griquas 0 0 quelques ali hammami 65
tous cas les particules et l'allemagne
tout comme mouvement c'est qu'on va il
ya plus de mouvement thermique aléatoire
ils sont piqués par un bain thermique
comme l'inde sait les molécules dans
leur température et viennent réchauffer
tous conçus mais n'en est plus au chaud
plus ils gagnent c'est ça c'est ça ça on
enlève pliage de lâches
et qu'on enlève la chaleur systèmes
comme un gant mais il reste toujours un
mouvement si le mouvement
no cantique des cantiques
parce qu'il ya toujours une vibration
quanti c'est comme une corne ses cordes
quand ils ne peuvent pas été défigurée
n'existe pas l'état ou qui sont plaintes
ils font toujours de la musique c'est
des électrons dans les fonds c'est ça le
gamin
je vois comme toujours une libération
coincé fait qu'à dessus enlève la
chaleur d'un système tu enlèves le
mouvement thermique aléatoire souvient
révélé met en évidence les mouvements
intrinsèque coin
puis s'avère en fait quelqu'un qui
refroidit un système
l'espère ondulatoire d'un électron par
exemple augmentent avec l'ong devine
plus en plus grands l'homme dont on
parlait tout à l'heure c'est ça ces
électrons sinon on active mais quand je
refais roizy quand j'enlève le challenge
stand la halle augmentant les temps du
spatial a donné une plus grande puis
dans un supraconducteur ce qui arrive
c'est que
c'est pas les électrons en fait qui font
la job c'est les électrons ils
deviennent un peu amoureux ils forment
des pins avec deux électrons ses seuls
le nouveau building la russie prend
une attraction qui se produit dans des
matériaux comme l'aluminium à
température très très très basse une
attraction qui s'opère les électrons
fait qu'ils forment des pères puis
chaque paire sont nombreux et de plus en
plus grande qu on refroidit une
température critique ou ce que toutes
les zones deviennent essentiellement la
main on a une onde macroscopique de
matière c'est comme toutes les ondes se
superposent de manière exactement en
forme
l'image qu'on donne des fois c'est comme
une folle où ce que tous les gens
seraient exactement le même cerveau ils
font la même chose chef d'orchestre qui
dit à tout le monde qui bat la mesure
puis tout le monde
ljg ces enfants sont comme tout parent
fait comme un banc de poissons des fois
que j'ai vu ça quand il nage pour sauver
d'un prédateur serment même c'est ça il
y en ait mouvement peace et ça c'est
impressionnant les électrons ou les
peurs d'électrons du profond ça aussi
comme une folle dans un chaudron mais ce
serait un bond en sens inverse ce exact
mais comme tout le monde était ensemble
il ya pas de collision en collision ce à
dire que deux personnes font des choses
différentes qui se rentrent dedans je
vais pas se rentrer dedans dans cette
foule là où les poissons dans la main un
livre ils sont tout enfant s'ils se
rendent jamais dedans donc pas de perte
contrairement aux rams et un problème
mais admettons qu'on voit
texte d'un charme maintenant on le voit
le nuage
comme l'espèce de
deux nuages de probabilités de
positionnement de l'électro une fois
qu'on le mesure si les nuages est
extrêmement
long et les c'est comme si
l'électronique comme partout en même
temps j'étais bien compris oui ok ce
sera fait le don qui voyage comme
voyager à une vitesse
est presque finie sais pas qui voyagent
ceux qui partout en même temps ils sont
en mission je sais comment dizaine
d'accords de guitare qui s y est ce que
les situations se propagea lez lille
très rapidement jusqu'à non il est pas
noir dans l'est une corde de longueur
comme toi matériaux dans le fond c'est
ça le sport en général pas à faire des
trop gros comme la table on n'arrive pas
à accepter
un pressentiment les gens qui ont
vraiment des guides des guides pour
transporter ses perles se défile c'est
vrai que ça peut être étendu mais ça
c'est pas comme infiniment parce qu'ils
étaient contraints par les contraintes
du matériau c'est dans la surface mais
qui fait que ça prend un fils fakim
froid exact ça c'est coûteux donc on
sauverait pas d'énergie faut que ça faut
que le ferry complaire f3 on avait
peut-être la clé froid noms qui restent
froides parce que l'aluminium comme dans
le micro il en a sûrement il est
possible qu'on dit en présentant ce qui
est trop chaud pour que soit ce prop qui
s'est prêté la doc une résistance
électrique aucune collision c'est mon
enfance il faut qu'ils soient
c'est moins deux cent soixante dix
degrés celsius c'est juste quelques
degrés en hausse de 0 absolue fixée
extrêmement coûteux refroidir
l'aluminium à s'aplatir là c'est pour ce
que nos fils hydro et à la maison son
poids supraconducteurs parce que mon
père est trop d'énergie allait refroidir
avec une des bus dans mon domaine de la
science la science des matériaux s'est
trouvé des supras à température de plus
en plus élevés et éventuellement
température de pièces acquis et puis
c'est une possibilité une possibilité
c'est un rigolo qu'on connaît pas ce
matériau le mans pense qu'il peut
exister
on aimerait ça qui existent mais
peut-être principes physiques qu'on n'a
pas encore qui nous dit que c'est
impossible mais je dirais que la réponse
est sûrement qui existe parce que ces
temps ci les gens ont découvert des des
matériaux que si tu mets une pression
immense dessus qui ont des manières
d'écran il matériaux qui est une manière
très très forte affection dépression
immense you des matériaux qui deviennent
supraconducteurs
les températures pas mal proche de
perdre sur pièces afférentes aux
placements semaine pression dessus tu as
l'empêchent de gigoter comme on dit dans
tout ça c'est un peu plus compliqué que
ça et des enfants mécanismes et ses
sauts ce qui arrive c'est
parce que c'est un peu plus subtile ce
qui arrive quand une grosse pression tu
vient accentuer le romantisme et les
électrons les bains bon débarras
facilement appelé par son plus fort que
sa foi des couples qui sont forts pas
son proche non loin des yeux loin du
coeur avec la grosse pression rapproche
les attentes qui s'accentue cette colle
l'un qui collent les électrons qui
forment départ puis les parts après font
leur job puis une fois que la danse et
danse et ses étudiants qui sont faites
une fois qu'il est la pression et est
effectué si on relâche la pression est
ce que on se sont parlés les capacités
de supraconducteurs c'est comme ça me
réchauffe il le conserve le ton de dire
c'est pas plus c'est pas plus réalisable
de faire ce genre ce type de
supraconducteurs là que ceux à zéro
absolu en fait c'est moins réaliste
sauf que ça nous dit c'est que ya
possiblement des chances qu'on puisse le
faire à température bus tout ça mais il
ya quand même d'autres matériaux qui
existent ou seppi qui sont à la pression
les écrase pas qui de plus en plus lui
température moins 200 - j'espère me
rendre ici voici que le record mais
centaines de quelven ça commence à se
rapprocher des céramiques un peu spécial
avec des plans de cuir oxydes des choses
comme celui de ces matériels a donc les
gens commencent à les y a pas besoin de
pression qui sont encore à tours de plus
élevés puis à chaque 5 1 et on augmente
un petit peu dans cette course et ça
augmente un peu mais pas tellement c'est
ainsi sa ceinture quand même mais c'est
en haut de l'azoté liquide avec les
autres liquides c'est quand même
important pour les technologies parce
que c'est plus facile à se procurer que
d'autres zilina réfrigérant
c'est moins cher que l'hélium cellules
sont très très très bon que ça devient
liquide azote liquide c'est plus chaud
ça reste froid j'adore les litres
c'est moi qu'elle garde
fait qu'il y en a qui existe entre les
autres liquides fait que ces liquidités
suffisant pour refroidir puis reçu
profite d'ailleurs dans les écoles
contre les expériences des foi des
démons pour montrer un supra ben c'est
cela qui a man oxydes de cuivre une
formule chimique et le comble c'est
important mais l'azoté liquide dessus
devient support dumas sur un aimant puis
il évite les enfants aiment ce bâtiment
on aime ça moi-même j'adore ce fait
signe à chaque fois
mais les autres liquides ça reste froid
pour faire ça à l'échelle de l'hydro
amené d'amener de la baie james jusqu'à
ici c'est à flacq des sports en
laboratoire est capable d'en faire une
escapade en face à des petites distances
mais la belgique mais c'était quand même
des réseaux de trains au japon qui
fonctionnent avec des supraconducteurs
réseau des trains qu'il ait vue
politiquement la crm grosse grande
distance là mais pas à l'échelle d'un
réseau d'hydro-québec j'ai passé
convaincu la matante houleux mais c'est
immense j'abonde rentrée plusieurs
finales québec avait déjà fait 10 mai
comme acquis et comment qui
entretiennent leurs suppôts compte
twitter peau qui situe sur un
réfrigérant
sur toute la distance du trajet l'e10
dont s'est poliment ce me semble mais
quelle classe à ce petit jeu c'est
quelqu'un que le rythme et si c'est pas
des c'est pas montréal vancouver c'est
même pas un pot tokyo kyoto
mais c'est ça m'apparaît comme étant
vraiment une
une avenue qui est qui
prometteuse parce que l'énergie c'est
quelque chose qui est
qui qui va être cela l'enjeu la denrée
la plus importante dans le futur nature
l'énergie renouvelable qui capable de
larmes en pis si qui s'apprête quoi
béton mais tant qu'on réussit la
découvrir justement c'est le matériau le
supraconducteur la température y est ce
que ça pourrait que ça ferait comme
révolution dans le monde dans le monde
qu'on connaît belle première manche
l'imprimeur
important personnellement c'est une fois
sauf tellement d'énergie si matériaux
que tu découvres premièrement c'est pour
un matériau rare parce qu'un accident
tant que matériau mais ça prend des
attentes qu'on trouve pas souvent dans
ton camp se creuse dans les mines au
québec c'est que la chine contrôle de
certaines mines fait que ça devient très
très cher et on a très peur avec à ce
manque quelque chose qui est
relativement abondant mais là ça change
tout une business de file - qui devient
l'homme la femme la plus puissante
dans l'univers connu
et aussi d'autres applications parle
beaucoup de transport du coin parce que
c'est
très très très pertinent mais
qu'on fait une image récente magnétique
à l'hôpital
l'acronyme irm on nous plonge dans un
gros gros gros champ magnétique puis
pour le faire ça principes conducteurs
en fait quand on rend dans cette machine
là ils refusent la grosse machine avec
un gros rompions d'une vision moi j'ai
jamais fait mais oui mais tu vois tes
rappelé dans un grand cylindre à des
pillards m c'est pour toi c'est pas que
tu es dans un cerveau c'est pour
reprendre dès lundi au bâton en d2 et
participe à des radios mais ça s'est
passé tout est dit
ces projets sur le cerveau ce n'est
porté que le tissu qui n'importe quel
tissu est vraiment ça prend ça s'apprend
6-1 supraconducteurs dans cette machine
va il faut le refroidir et les hôpitaux
sont très très très dépendants de 10
procure id de l'hélium liquide pour les
refroidir à des températures d'à peu
près - 270 degrés celsius et l'hélium
liquide ça coûte excessivement chaps une
denrée qui très très très très très rare
parce qu'il est gay c'est tellement
logique à partir du moment où on ne part
ils s'envolent dans la haute atmosphère
pays sort de l'orbité reste donc
l'hélium une fois qu on ne dira jamais
perdu à jamais ou si c'est très
dangereux qui est très critique mais je
me rappelle moi je n'utilisais quand
j'ai quand je travaillais en post doc
mans n'est pas ce qu'on trouve souvent
dans les nappes ou est-ce qu'ils
extraient le pétrole puis il ya eu un
conflit entre 14 je pense l'arabie
saoudite et tout d'un coup les les prix
les liens avaient monté énormément donc
il faut comprendre qu'un immense enjeu
pour toutes les zones et les lire les
hôpitaux à travers le monde devait
effectivement que si on trouve un autre
supraconducteurs qui est plus accessible
ce en faisant savoir réduire les coûts
grandement puis aussi la l'espèce de
l'axé fragilité habitude clairement on
est tout à l'heure on parlait des
centrales de fusion nucléaire pour
produire l'énergie plutôt que de prendre
des gros attendent les quotients de
fer d'énergie prendre deux petits at-on
blekko les intrus ça fait aussi
d'énergie mais ça c'est très dur tout
n'est pas capable on y voit qu'avec le
talent et le fait très bien on peut le
faire sous des conditions existant avec
de l'argent très puissant c'est juste
qu'on met plus d'énergie qu'on en
ressort une habile en exil et comme
c'est une équipe qui fait tout ça où on
est positif pendant une milliseconde
mais ça prend décrochant magnétique pour
confiner le ségala et les gens ont
besoin de gros crocro aimant aussi donc
ça va être un enjeu sont le produit
aussi des centrales d'énergie qui qui
produisent pas de déchets radioactifs
aucun déchet radioactif parce que tu
pars d'être produit de l'hélium ou du
produit des attentes très très léger qui
sont complètement il n'y a pas des
produits comme williams dit tout à
l'heure cd c'est pas des processus qui
s'emballe puis continuer longtemps mais
ça s'apprend des très très très gros
chamagne son
souci c'est qu'elle augure de l'énergie
finalement son récent passé comme
révolutionnant la pierre philosophale
belle à la fusion nucléaire quand même
beaucoup d'argent investi là-dedans
surtout ce 2 juin elle saisit en europe
mais
c'est le soleil l'a fait parce qu'il est
tellement massif la gravité celles qui
comprennent les attentes qui fusionne
sortant se fout l'application
première je pensais des gens là prennent
des lasers la mort pour écraser il doit
tomber de rage en une par une il y
sommes plus sur leur énergie puis cap
sur l'énergie que tu recommences s'est
pas encore rentable qu'un processus face
à quelle vitesse ce qui lie les études
autour de la physique quantique la
mécanique quantique est ce que c'est ça
avance est ce que george est
exponentielle comment maintenant vingt
dernières années commenté ça a été
depuis le lit l'avancement
récemment jacques dallest
dix des quinze dernières années mais dix
dernières années surtout il ya une
grosse grosse grosse accélération parce
que les recherches ont commencé à sortir
aussi des universités il commence à y
avoir de plus en plus d'entreprises qui
ont des divisions quantique qui ont un
intérêt aux autres vous êtes pour faire
d'autres choses au point ce serait
vraiment intéressant d'en parler mais
ils veulent ils veulent fabriquer
d'autres types de dispositifs par
exemple l'ordinateur c'est ça sa carte
fonctionne a entendu parler de ces temps
ci lui seul mérite pas ça me semble
compliqué fish est profonde dès qu'on
parle si la prochaine l'autre c'est
l'idée à la base à la boisson juste
d'être perdante un thriller parce que
philippe travailler pour l'entreprise
montréalaise qui fait construire des
ordinateurs quantiques 3g fabrique les
conçoivent les faits ça existe déjà
c'est la mort ayant une idée si ça
existe dans les grandes villes mais même
à montréal on est entre exactement ce
qu'ont fait ces cdd des prototypes
beaucoup à travers le monde n'a pas eu
ça m'ouvrira le portier dans le monde
donc on est un peu à l'époque des vous
savez les attaques des deux seules
villes où est ce qu'on fait les gens les
gens utilisaient ces immenses et c'est
énorme mais on commence à se rendre
compte que ça marchait mieux que que
faire des calculs qui ont un jour tout
le monde vont nous rentrer chez lui
poser
ouais ensuite on va pouvoir quitter ce
que tout le monde les sens que ça va
reproduire la
popularité de l'autre classique mais oui
on est on est en poste à ce niveau là
et si on revient un peu à la base c'est
ce que c'est c'est on parlait tout à
l'heure de ces objets individuels qui se
comportent comme des ombres puis à la
base c'est les fondateurs de la
mécanique quantique inquiet qui propose
à six dès la 10è imaginons qu'on soit
capable un jour
projet de voir les électrons m'aider
l'isoler des l'isoler un électron ou un
atome ou un grain de lumière de ce qu'on
appelle un photon peu importe
êtes-vous l'isoler vous êtes capable de
le contrôler imaginons qu'on soit
capable de faire simple il disait
toujours bien entendu c'est complètement
fou sera jamais capable de faire ça
d'accord imaginons qu'on soit capable
pour les biens de la discussion les il
va se faisait suivre les règlements les
choses ont fait recours au web les gens
sont capables de faire ça sont capables
d'isoler et
c'est vraiment un domaine que j'appelle
de duilhac beaucoup de gens appellent du
génie quanti faire de l'ingénierie de
systèmes on est capable de venir isolés
ces particules elle est contrôlée pour
faire des buts bien précis pour faire
justement du traitement de l'information
pour faire de la communication le
prendre l'envoyer à longue distance pour
faire des protocoles de transfert
d'information des banques y visera une
compagnie en suisse qui équipe qui offre
ses services de cryptographie dans des
criques routier hockey est par exemple
les banques ou les gouvernements sont
parmi leurs clients et mais si on
revient et l'ordinateur quantique c'est
de se dire que habituellement dans un
ordinateur on on le nom en tant qu est
ce que ça fait ça prend de l'information
ça fait des opérations
sa ordonne un peu les ce que vous
rentrez sur votre clavier ou ce que vous
rentrez par votre micro et ça ressort
quelque chose d'utile après avoir fait
une série d'opérations vous rentrez des
chips et les additionne vous rentrez des
chiefs avant d'étriller vous rentrez des
images sa volée classé il naîtra une
machine extraits comment la machine
fonction de ces cas prend vos écrans et
les divise un an buts à 0 et 1 1 avec
des protocoles bien compris
ce qu'on peut faire avec un autre auteur
contexte plutôt que de séparer en
éléments de base qui sont des bits
d'information soit des héros ou des
seins on utilise le fait qu'on peut être
deux choses en même temps mécanique
quantique parce que c'est justement
c'est the bellrays comportent comme des
ombres on est un peu 0 est un peu un à
la fois et on peut contrôler exactement
combien on les héros combien on est un
et donc ce qu'on appelle un bit
quantique un cube it.com byte quand on
habite et
chacun des électrons là chacun des
atomes sa de bill conti de cupides et là
vous en mettez plusieurs ensembles et
vous les faites enfin on fait le rôle
d'un ingénieur quantique c'est un peu
que moi je le vois souvent communs un
peu comme un luthier vous savez
quelqu'un crever qu'une guitare il veut
s'assurer que la forme de sa vie par la
caisse de résonance va parfaite pour
bien piéger les laisons il nous en a
c'est petit onglet qui sont beaucoup
plus petites microscopiques et on veut
fabriquer des petit petit petit petit
système qui vont les piéger et qui vont
les faire rester de façon bien bien bien
précises et on peut changer
dynamiquement c'est comme si je
changeais uniquement ma cage de
résonance et hors jeu peut commencer à
faire des opérations changement ma
composition se déroule un pour mon bits
ou j'en prends deux cages de résidence
et un à côté de l'autre et je commence à
les couples et un halo s commence à
faire une certaine le patron
d'interférence entre les différents mais
différents mais différents b et
lorsque la machine fait ce qu'elle fait
à modifier toutes ces caisses de
résonance ya les coupes les découpes
l'egypte comme ça c'est le style
l'utilisateur qui décide qu'agent de
faire éventuellement au bout du de
l'algorithme on regarde le patron
d'interférences et ça donne une réponse
à une question est ce que c'est les gens
montrer c'est que cette façon de traiter
l'information là plutôt que de faire des
opérations sur des airs aux idées des
uns mais plutôt que d'utiliser ces zones
là qu'on est couplé les unes aux autres
ça peut être excessivement avantageux
pour certaines tâches bien précises
qu'on connaît bien précis prix qui ont
des applications réelles pour des
entreprises par exemple pour faire de
l'optimisation cixi chez un vendeur qui
doit aller voir 150 maisons dans quelle
heure de jeu de rallye faire pour sauver
du temps et ça c'est extrêmement
pertinent pour plein de gens présentent
un québec qui veut planifier son réseau
donc on fabrique un système avec nos
bits quantiques no kill bits et on on
programme pour résoudre ce truc là puis
est-ce que ce ça opera une vitesse plus
grande qu'un ordinateur comme comme on
le connaît c'est certain temps je sais
pas tout les temps je congrès accélérer
une manière dramatique juste certaines
tâches bien précises
le bout on sait pas encore en fait
l'horizon de caisse qui veut accélérer
de manière c'est avantageuse mais on a
des exemples plusieurs exemples de temps
qu'un ordi classique
révélateur ce printemps lors du côtier
qui se prendrait exponentiellement moins
de temps
extrêmement plus un dvd principal des
principales tâches qu'on peut faire
c'est face qu'est-ce que oui a fait
simuler des matériaux simuler des
matériaux est plutôt que d'avoir un
ordinateur qui dit qu'ils essaient de
reproduire la physique des atomes
comment il sa chance entre eux puis
qu'est ce que ça donne mais au bout du
compte mais on fait vraiment des
éléments de base quantique qui on les
regarde évoluer puis on regarde les
résultats s qui donnait ainsi pro
conducteur est ce que devient magnétique
ça c'est l'idée de fin de mission
l'heureuse qu'annabelle très célèbre
très éloquent aussi qui s'est dit
certain qu'à stimuler la physique
quantique soit l'heure dite classique
ces flux sont handicapantes inc j'ai
fait une machine qui fait la critique
directe de casernes de réponse sur la
war plus vite et mieux comme pas des
simulations finalement rentré des
données de on parle souvent des
simulateurs pompiers pour venir simuler
des matières n'en parle aussi
d'ordinateurs pour vraiment faire un peu
comme un ordinateur faire de faire des
opérations logiques bien précise et
c'est avantageux pour pour certaines
tâches bien précises pour d'autres c'est
pas ce qu'on fait habituellement avec
nos ordinateurs classiques à libourne
aux courriers si c'est pas des suppôts
des tâches qui sont avantageuses à
cannes en tant qu on sait qu on parle
beaucoup d'applications pour l'instant
que l'application academy d'applications
industrielles
mais il faut comprendre que c'était
aussi les applications qui était à la
base de l'ordinaire à l'époque des des
ordinateurs d'être déçu bible et un jour
on a commencé à les fabriquer pour de
vrai ses ordres et de façon beaucoup
plus robuste et on les a mis dans les
mains d'autres chercheurs de d des
ingénieurs des chimistes des médecins
des biologistes je dirais sûrs ont
inventé toutes sortes d'applications
puis aujourd'hui les orientations
partout est-ce qu'ils vont être partout
ils vont sûrement se propager comme ça
mais c'est dur d'évaluer leur
trajectoire dans le panorama mais il y
en a tellement un potentiel de pouvoir
s'est propagée loin qu'il ya beaucoup
beaucoup d'intérêt le fait et
et bien malin qui pourra dire quelle va
être la trajectoire exacte mais je crois
qu est ce qu il faut avoir en tête c'est
que cette trajectoire là va être quand
même majeurs mais ce qu'on une déco
manque ça peut influencer
comment qui lisent mans et on s'organise
on fonctionnait ce que tu dis est ce que
ce conseiller si on ne les entends qu on
dit que ça changerait tyler était le
problème c'est ce qu'ont une des eaux
sinon c'est pas encore parce que les
ordis qu'on a aujourd'hui sont tellement
petit
c'est une belle et bien par exemple ils
font des ordis quantique
qui citait plusieurs millions dizaines
de millions dans la période en
l'achetant acheter un
ces gens te le redis quantique celle
environ s'est ensuite des dizaines de
qubits voire des centaines elles
éliminent bmc une centaine il nous a
redit son cellulaire mais des milliards
2 millions d'habitants une différence
immense c'est très petit système parce
qu'on arrive pas à ce qu'ils aient
laissé à grande échelle
fait que les applications aujourd'hui
c'est très très limité c'est plus pour
montrer dans certaines situations on
leur dit qu'on en dise plus bas lors du
classique mais prévoir des courriels
c'est pour jouer à pacman sympa c'est
6000 plants d'oignons du classique les
conseillers pourront s'en vont avec ça
mais en recherche fondamentale et des
gens dit en chimie ou en bio qu'ils
pensent l'apprenti leur dis là pour
faire des meilleurs médicaments on
cherchait un médicament de manière plus
efficace puisque leur dit qu un truc
pour faire des choses en parallèle en
même temps que l'on dit classés ne
pourrait pas faire faire ce qu'ils
peuvent faire du tri de médicaments
théoriquement en parallèle pour
découvrir plus facilement le médicament
qui fait la forme pour l'accueillir par
exemple fait que je te dirais que c'est
dans l'application des gens y pensent ou
mardi mais la batterie on doit investir
et salengro somme pour acheter tandis qu
en tic pour améliorer ses batteries
parce qu'il ya des fonds ni voiture
électrique les batteries ce matin
direction de mieux en mieux donc qui est
des compagnies immense qui investissent
des sommes immenses là dedans mon est
encore au point où ce que c'est un game
boy et on sait pas se voir les ou mais
on sent que le potentiel est là puis
avec l'argent qui me je soupçonne que
les choses dans le centre c'est comme un
marathon puis les gens si les gros joie
sentant de sa place et puis c'est de
dire que celui qui va gagner celui qui
est en avant du peloton c'est lui parce
que les gens sont en train de se classer
mais vraiment les gros joueurs c'est
gougaud qu'une grosse division
d'ordinateurs quantiques amazon ibm
intel en eux ou alors des grosses
compagnies comme microsoft ils ont
toutes ses divisions la mettait pour
revenir est ce que tu disais tout à
l'heure qu'est-ce que ça va changer dans
nos vies je pense que c'est des fois
c'est dur d'imaginer que va devenir une
technologie
puis il y avait un physicien en ontario
qui est un québécois
la base et raymond laflamme qui avait
utilisé cette analogie là ils disaient
vous savez depuis depuis toujours les
gens inventent des sources de lumière on
est passé du feu
aux lampes à l'huile et ont pour
l'électrique fluocompactes dire d'être
innocente aujourd'hui chacune a comme
remplacer un peu la précédente parce
qu'il était meilleur que l'eau au milieu
du 20ème siècle les gens ont commencé à
faire d'autres sources ou la lumière
sortait un peu comme dans un sip raconte
yvan toutant phase ce qu'on appelle un
laser aujourd'hui c'est sûr puis les
gens ont dit saint lazare à la basse les
gens disaient avoir quelques
chefs-d'oeuvre dégénéré on est capable
de faire des sources de lumière o'toole
et tous les photons sorte exactement
france nous mais à quoi ça ça c'est
surtout chine tous nos problèmes c'est
une solution au canard blanc mais
éventuellement on a commencé à fabriquer
et pierre à les rendre de plus en plus
axée cpie des médecins ont commencé à
utiliser des chimistes et biologistes
aujourd'hui on fête la découpe dans des
dents des industries des feuilles
d'acier ont fait de la chirurgie mais le
dise ce que les disques de dvd internet
internet comme les tous les signaux
internet travail sont 130 transportés
par fibre optique à partir de des lasers
personne personne qui dans les gens qui
fabriquent elles et lazaro début aurait
pu imaginer ça parce que c'est vraiment
pas là je pense que c'est ça aussi les
chaudes qui aurait pensé que les jeunes
bénéficierait du losange l'internet
c'est l'avant pour le bien être
c'est ça c'est sympa quand dire qu
il ya comme une fois que la digue
ambitions et d'humilité donné l'ambition
de faire ça mais aussi d'éliminer
peut-être pas savoir qu'est-ce qui va
emmener parce que on n'est pas des
biologistes on n'est pas des chimistes
on n'est pas du tout le monde n'a pas la
science infuse dans tous les domaines
mais selon des livres de renty machine
là
accessible de les rendre performante de
l'iran des moindrement plug and play
pour qu'on puisse bâtir est des vrais et
structure son campus comme à l'époque et
notre moral premier premier ordinateur
les gens venaient avec leurs cartes
perforées et puis faisait des calculs
les mutuelles membres les choses vont
émerger
on a décidé de conférer constamment vers
le laser à l'époque on savait pas ça
sera quand on a commencé déjà des avec
des idées dsk quoi ça pourrait servir
mais c'est si c'est loin de ça c'est
juste le temps qu'ils vont me dire je
pense que lorsque personne qui peut
aujourd'hui lisez cette sauce de soja
une vidéo
de l'entrevue
domaine avec bill gates ça je pense
qu'en 1995
puis il fait bill gates qui dit et pas
moins de sept ans à faire le d'internet
là c'est quoi ce qui fait ça va
révolutionner le monde la supplique
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire avec ceux qui
bâtissent par exemple vous pourrez
écouter une gaine de football à travers
internet ouais mais je pense que des
jeux de l'écouter non mais aussi
l'écouté quand tu veux plus c'était
vraiment tendu par les enregistreurs
claudie comme il ya peu la gueule
on est et on n'a pas de problème pigeons
à faire d'internet
sont déjà finalement ça a complètement
changé le cours du match
effectivement c'est un exemple pour
montrer que les technologies
on sait jamais où ça va venir ce sont
les livres de science fiction sont
remplis d'idées qui était brillant
pendant un peuple qui apparaissent
aujourd'hui complètement loufoque mais
c'est important de lancer des idées même
si kate apparaît tel un parce que mon
année c'est ça aussi mais pour l'heure
dit coantic si on avait un ordi assez
gros ce qui est des tanches importante
qu'on pourrait faire manière très
accéléré ce une raison que les
gouvernements les militaires les grosses
compagnies veulent pas que leurs
concurrents en ayant une machine à même
sens que lui en est l'une des questions
de sécurité aussi parce qu'il n'est
magnan qu'on protège des formations avec
l'incription rs 1
grosso modo série va facturer des gros
noms un facteur plus petits ces deux
fois 4 s'est
trouvé que ces deux fois 4 le nom de l'
avantage pour décrypter le message puis
volé
il s'avère que notre
exemple on a la recette pour la fin puis
on sait que ça marche jusqu on n'a pas
cette subite pour la phase des gros
chiffres qu'on utilise dans nos
transactions car des crédits des lacs
mais on sait que cnn qui arrive tout le
système la crypte sion qui tend en place
en place maintenant et tombe à l'eau
donc les gens parlent du prêt par
l'alarmé c'est un des grands clients
c'était
la nommer agnès système ce qui est à
dorval notre premier client avait été la
défense canadien qu'est ce que tu peux
en parler ou tu viens de
brésiliens mais
quel genre de course à ce que les
personnes qui veulent manquer le train
parce que ça pourrait être
révolutionnaire mais on ne sait pas
exactement mais si c'est les lions
veulent d'abord puis à plusieurs
approches il ya des gens qui veulent
fabriquer avec avec des attentes y'en a
que fabriquent des électrons fabriquer
des faux fabriqué avec des petites
boucles du circuit sera construit comme
chacun sait les ventes et le transistor
puis chacun a ses avantages ses
inconvénients api mais ce serait un pur
sang plateforme
servant de support aux des applications
déçu pour eux je pense et des
plateformes les plus populaires et bien
me sentir un lien de systèmes sens on se
prend des supports pour faire des
culbutes fait que c'est une application
intéressante inusité des supras car le
supporter découvert dans les années 1900
gmac est le monsieur qui refroidissent
ans et 10 ans le nouvel ordinateur qui
va changer parce qu'ils aiment pas
d'entraîneur classé que ces peuples mais
l'entente plus tard savard est le
building langue pour plusieurs
plateformes dandy cuincy fait que c'est
un exemple d'application que tu peux pas
imaginer quand même couverture machine
ça je sais quoi c'est l'application des
récentes de sa sphère du public
on parlais tantôt des simulations
quantique est ce que les ordinateurs
quantiques ci dessus s'ils sont capables
de simuler par exemple les les effets de
où la création du supra ou est capable
de stimuler ses théories la hesse qui
sont gardés simuler autre chose
maintenant je pense à ont parlé des
médicaments thiès qui sont capables de
voir maintenant si on est capable de
rentrer dans l'ordinateur quantique les
les paramètres dans
cerveau de chômeurs dont on est capable
de voir qu'est-ce que potentiellement
les médicaments pourraient faire sur ce
pourrait éventuellement à éviter je
parle
mallié mais vite et mettons de devoir
faire des tests sur des animaux sur dix
pourraient pas répondre à cette question
spécifique moi je sais pas les aspects
de la réponse mais est ce qu'une chose
qu'on pourrait faire par exemple en ce
qu on peut simuler la quel genre de
molécules peuvent se former puis à quoi
vont ressembler donc les médicaments à
la basse et une molécule qu'on peut
synthétiser nôtres habituellement ce
qu'on fait c'est qu'enfin on synthétise
un paquet de molécules qui on regarde
les qu'on les regarde par après lesquels
sont bonnes pour lesquels sont pas
bonnes depuis on en synthétique c'est
comme une chaîne d'habillement ou est-ce
qu'on fabrique choses qui sont 99% du
temps si c'est pas bon de temps en temps
c'est bon le second à la recette
lorsqu'on peut faire si le faire sur un
ordinateur le faire sans être obligé de
activement le crée ensuite on peut les
synthétiser puis regarder s'il me faut
le tester et éventuellement sur des
29 ans y fit comme des sourds ils n'ont
ebola de soucis mais
s'est créé comme un show s'il ya un chat
c'est très compliqué j'imaginerais
l'horizon de sa dot être très très loin
dans le futur je pense des rentrées
toutes les données de ce qu'est un choc
qu'ordinateur à est vraiment le chemin
nantis bas si on s'entend que chaque
cupide c'est comme un support au 31 mars
au-dessus prône une petite grenade de ce
prix fait soit par écrit un show exact
va requérir une simulation d'un choix
faits cliquetant faudrait à des cupides
pour faire ça puis juste c'est quand
même des choses plus simples le comédien
quand je suis symbolique et déjà gloire
c'est ça pour l'instant c'est des
systèmes c'est beaucoup plus 5 pour 1
c'est comme c'est un fils quoi antique
où ce que à chaque site dont 206 nathan
fils contexte une chaîne à la queue leu
leu dates ont été chaque city par action
voisin c'est tout déjà ça c'est
compliqué le multi un cheikh salah 10
l'a23 attentes et impie 23,0 apprennent
ça c'est des chefs qu'on peut pas
comprendre
et qu'on est très loin d'être sans plus
produire les molécules mathy de faire
les tests si voir si ça fonctionne
vraiment
c'est souvent
des gens qui s'intéressent à au
traitement d'image des choses comme ça
façon plus fait oui et et quand on
regarde des images par irm est ce qu'on
est capable de traiter plus rapidement
pour pau il situe faire défaire des
opérations mais sa demande si sa demande
vraiment dans les applications qui sont
les plus long terme - vraiment les plus
long terme l'on est vraiment plus dans
puis désossé c'est déjà immense mais on
est vraiment plus d'en optimiser des
autochtones et des procédés factoriser
des normes pour
simuler des molécules simuler des
matériaux simples les choses qu'eux
mêmes ne sommes pas là d un noir c'est
sardines c'est trop complexe énormément
d'attentes dans cette molécule
c'est face à
cette existence et puis en fait un point
intéressant récemment l'actualité le
gouvernement de l'angola cac qui ont
investi des sommes assez immense
récemment dans justement l'ordinateur
quantique c'est dans la région de brome
en estrie trompait ont fait nommer son
majeur sur les technologies coin 6 qui
est toujours du coin tic donc le
gouvernement aussi québécois vont
l'importance de super investi des sommes
d'immenses sont gentilles notre argent
des impôts fait convoquer momentum
vraiment que françois legault dise le
mot quantique
la pauvreté existe encore mariée maman
table mondiale puis c'est chapeau au
québec et au canada au canada aussi a
vraiment des initiatives puis
il ya très très peu de pays en europe en
amérique du nord en australie en inde et
en chine japon là où ou le lac on tique
est pas passé sous le radar
c'est en train de d'émerger en tout cas
d'aller dans les plates formes de
financement de la science
j'ai des questions plus par rapport à
venir plus à la théorie pure mais tendu
la physique le tipi et si je vais
demander de semer tombe lectra
ce ca
ge energy
qui prennent des d12 at-on ils font
tourner puis ils font rentrer se rentrer
dedans une vitesse incroyable si je
comprends bien c'est un peu poussée des
protons et proton proton qui collision
frontale et d énergie incroyable plus il
le pour voir
quelles particules encore plus petites
sont composés parce que le il explose un
peu le pont plus ample et les mesures in
le 6 ans que je prends le manquer mais
c'est sur c'est la question démocrate
encore gagner toujours du plus petit
pitch salle a permis de mesurer le boson
de higgs par exemple mettons substitut
ça a été discuté comme une des plus
grandes découvertes dans le monde
physique mettons alors au bord de l'eau
c'est pourquoi si c'est important cette
découverte le 6 et 6 c'est quoi cette
particule ok bonne question
180 degrés annoncés
staline c'est quoi les ingrédients qui
forment le maintien moi c'est les
électrons les protons neutrons mais
quand il frappe de pro temps semble-t-il
viennent détruire le proton parce que le
proton est pas un dit viser une fête
c'est la plus petite partie qu'on
appelle des quark chaque proton grosso
modo est faite de trois quark
ces quads et coire nos questions puis en
même temps il peut d'y croire qu'ils
sont générés tu génères d'autres
particules parce que einstein nous a dit
l'énergie c'est comme la masse égale mc2
aime c'est la masse de ces énergies c2c
la vitesse de mains au charisme
important pour ce mode haut de gamme
c'est l'énergie sur la masse et vice
versa fait qu'au sein du pôle énergie
pour la main ce boson de higgs parce que
l'extrême alors
[Musique]
c'est 100 g avait fait que le
convertissant en masse c'est très beau
c'est très lourd comparé les électrons à
des protons et neutrons à l'intérieur je
ne sais pas l'intérêt de la tombe c'est
partout dans l'univers en fait le boson
de higgs une particule qui fait partie
du modèle standard menace tendance est
là les ingrédients qui font l'univers
connu
non physique quantique comme le tableau
périodique des particules ça c'est plus
alimentaires que les attentes c'est tout
ce que la matière est fait est fait les
enfants là le modèle standard auquel et
quark les électrons puis une des
particules la modeste andorre qui est
pas mal nécessaire aux modèles son
modèle il se tient pas vraiment debout
si ce fameux boson de higgs là
le boson de higgs une des propriétés
fondamentales clairement c'est notre
meilleur électrique et qu'on peut pour
interagir avec un voltage s'est dit ni
positif ni négatif c'est ça une peau de
charges électriques communs à ton
globalement voilà si c'est le besoin de
l'exigé pas de structure mais pas de
charge fait que ces futurs interagir
avec pied pour une longue durée du non
plus d'en créer un
mais son rôle dans notre stand ans et
qui contribue à donner la masse aux
autres particules s'est pas laissé aller
faire parce que tu l'as marsa vient de
ou kiki dit que les trompettes autant
qui dit que le quark pas au top c'est
qu'on dit qu'on m'aiderait quelque chose
qu'on voit quelque chose si c'est qu'on
mesure sa masse dont on voit qu'ils
savent rien y est pour quelque chose
west petit effet sable comme encore non
mais c'est plus con qui est pour le
boson de higgs ou parce que ya pas de
charge électrique
pied pour une durée de vie qui très
langue fait 900 produits sains il va
s'intégrer rapidement puis même si
intégré pas dans les secteurs c'est dur
à
observer c'est à dire ça s'impose en 2 x
fait qui sera entièrement à certains
mais il se désintègre d'autres choses
pires mesurant les autres choses qu'ils
intègrent on peut déduire et un après
mais le standard que ceux-ci boson de
higgs ceux-ci s'amassent sur sa charge
ses fils à peu près ce qu'on s'attendait
oui c'est ce qu'ont été brisés ont fêté
les équations n'arrive est chef le monde
l'avait jamais mesuré c'est trop lourd
c'était trop lourd pour être ça prend
beaucoup d'énergie comme un william de
galles et
chaque fruit donner vraiment beaucoup
d'énergie pour qu'ils y apparaît puis le
hir deviennent energy s'est adressé en
gros la presse des intègre d'autres
particules sont plus les gens est plus
stable
puis en bout de l'émir est ce qui est le
plus stable ces dix ans
déclare que les électrons même des fois
tu hantes les réactions faute en général
semblent tellement bien mais ça c'est
parce que la lumière fait que besoin
d'exister théorique du hilal ans
building blocks anselme les standards
sont découvraient pas un peu dans les
problématiques de la physique on
comprend mieux vraiment la matière on
l'a découvert des masses qu'on
s'attendait aussi donc une grosse
découverte et un prix nobel là dessus ça
doit être là au bon moment
la bonne réaction c'est un moment de ouf
c'était pas un moment de huawei parce
que c'est pas une particule qui est très
exotique on s'attendait à ce qu'elle
soit là sauf que juste le fait qu'elle
existe et prouve que tout ce qui a été
construit après ça conceptualisations
tiens bon tiens debout et cohérent mais
les physiciens au cern ne s'était ainsi
il cherche quand même quelque chose qui
au du lot modeste andorre actuelle on
sait que la physique au-delà passait pas
complet on sait mais on n'a pas trouvé
encore de nouvelles particules ou de
nouvelles forces nouveau effet on
cherche encore cercle saint denis ont
soif de découverte surprenante le
n'existait pas surprenant que la musique
soit là c'est précis mais on essaie de
fonds éthiques et celle de la nouvelle
physique qui va nous propulser ailleurs
il est je pense l'avait fermée pour
qu'ils soient plus puissant plus rapide
puis les îles on va en espérant
justement avoir plus d'énergie pour
pouvoir trouver du neuf ans ce soit en
fait je me trompe pas l'énergie
politiquement tellement c'est plus le
nombre d'événements par seconde qui sont
capables de détecter ce un puits et
d'événements qui se produisent plutôt de
donner plus de trouver les choses rares
c'est comme trouver comme une aiguille
dans une botte des fins pas une botte de
foin fait que plus de plus tu es
beaucoup à chercher plus exactes ayant
augmenté beaucoup là la luminosité qu'on
dit le nombre d'événements qui se
produisent puis c'est ça la pression car
analyser ça parce qu'il donne et qui
sortent d'autres c'est absolument
abominable la quantité de données vers
gaza par des algorithmes et des gens qui
utilisent des ribs intelligence
artificielle pour aller extraire les
données par l'information pertinente de
cette mare immense de donner des
couleurs en tant que conseiller 28 mai
la fille est ce qui s pas trouver la
matière noire
fameuse et d'armes à feu
pourquoi pas s'ils espèrent espérer
c'était quelque chose sans savoir ça va
réveiller oui est ce qu'on s'attend tout
la matière sont aussi
parce que c'est une
bonne idée et qui existent sérieusement
oui oui léger théorise aider les gens
qui ont proposé des particules qui
serait là matière à 100 ma personne
c'est quoi ce la matière qu'on n'observe
pas dans l'univers mais qui est une
grande partie de la masse comment
concilier là parce que il ya des flics
attentionnel comme des planètes ou des
étoiles qui tourne autour d'un homme qui
tourne tellement vite que c'est
impossible clame à ce qu'on voit avec
les étoiles convoi fait que de la
matière qui a chez qui est noir ce
qu'ils retiennent ces planètes le hockey
de la voie des mesures et on la voit en
effet on voit l'effet sur les autres
astres qui tourne au taux effectif de
plus de la masse au milieu plus de faire
tourner les objets fascinants tu obtiens
quantique au milieu rien c'est ça pour
l'inspecter elle est sombre pour nos
yeux généralisée nos télescopes s'ils
sont si bonnes peignoir point de vue
comme le micro et noir noir nos
instruments nous nous on n'est pas
garante de capter 1 est fait en matière
de se rassembler au chantage et a
exhorté
ces
fous puis comment il pourrait que ça
ferait s'y trouvent se fait au jour le
jour ont certes imposant un show japoma
maintenant parce que
c'est comme les cafés tim hortons d'un
bond qui a fait si la chimie donc le
célèbre fois c'est l'équipe qui rentrent
en jeu toute la gravité s'est procuré un
thé les matières sont mon band dans
sûrement assez uniforme qui songerait ça
existe déjà et est on là autour de nous
est possiblement c'est ça mais ça
changera notre compréhension
fondamentale de l'univers on avait un
nouvel ingrédient ce qui fait l'univers
si on est comme avec son que c'est là où
on est rendu les débats des démocrates
et un risque que c'est quoi les
fondements
on est rendu à ce point là réfléchir à
ces choses là parce qu'on est capables
de bâtir des instruments que son père
d'avoir créé très petits voitures des
très grands aussi puis on se rend compte
qu'il ya des choses qui sont
inexplicables
avec les lois de la physique on connaît
donc se succéder ball et continuent et
continuent de battre fois se développe
c'est une vente cette question
scientifique lequel elles évoluent elles
évoluent au fur et à mesure qu'on
invente des instruments plus précis plus
plus efficace pour y voir plus loin aux
plus petits ceci est une opération
comprenant 7 à quoi vraiment on pourrait
comprendre l'univers à plus grande
échelle
c'est le big bang c'est pourquoi
l'univers est en expansion comme ça où
ce qu'on sent votre univers l'univers
rétracte éventuellement ce qui va
continuer à s'agrandir ces deux grandes
échelles c'est ce qu'on peut comprendre
mieux oh non non non la matière sont
dûment quand même une grosse pièce
d'information exaucer qu'il manque c'est
sa vie comme si la maintient il y en a
beaucoup la plus que la matière visible
à jouer un gros roman la gravité à
grande échelle
dans les équations cosmologique c'est à
grande échelle c'est un paramètre
important de ma terrasse en amont si
grosso modo la taille ne sais pas c'est
quoi la constitution ne tient fait que
ça serait monumental pour comprendre
l'univers la grande échelle - pour
comprendre notre quotidien baptisé
moyens en tant qu'êtres humains comprend
d'où on vient où ouvre ce serait très
important j'ai posé une question puis
écoute pas tant que tels que la réponse
est évidente mais si on prend en
considération que toute matière est
faite de mama six dates on
distingue
qu'en est il de la possibilité de la
téléportation
parce que non mais c'est moi c'est une
question qui tue parce que si on est
capable de prendre les attentes d
arrêter d bouger de faire un peu ce
qu'on veut avec qu'est ce qui nous
empêcherait de prendre toutes les
attentes d
amener une autre place belle
téléportation
y vont parce que
je crois bien entendu qu'on est capables
de s'insérer porter un atome cc 5e mais
plus elle est la théorie des ce cas
c'est ce qu'on appelle la téléportation
quantique ce qui est très très différent
de dire j'ai un objet je le détruise
endroit
doit disparaître d'après à quelques
porno c'est de dire les tontons et deux
électrons protons électrons et c'est
d'une certaine façon prévu que cette
situation là soient transférés à l'autre
électron votre transporté l'état contre
ils sont faits s'était vantée par un
chercheur de dieu merci montréal par le
bras ça oui et ça a été démontré après
ça paraît
ouais c'était une proposition
supposons que bah justement
g22 objets et il y en a un qui est dans
cet état de vibrations l'appui jeu
transféré cet été à l'autre comment le
thème prostate à une série d'opérations
du fep éventuellement de transférer tout
détruit d'un côté et le cias ion et le
cipi de la même façon mais si le
transfert est autre que tu tapes april
objets détruits pire est que les noter
c'est ce qu'on parle souvent quand on
parle tellement
c'était démontrer les gens l'ont
démontré pour vrai maintes et maintes
fois le board et des expériences même la
dernière fois que j'ai vu c'est des
objets qui sont de plus en plus plus en
plus éloignés les uns des autres mais
les objets comme des gibiers vue de
l'exportation sur des attentes sur des
électrons sur des défauts ton des choses
comme
ça qu'on parle d' objets on parle pas
d'une canette nous on parle de tout ce
qui pourrait utiliser parce que c'est
vraiment pertinent pour prendre
l'information qui disons par exemple
émotivement ton ordinateur quantique
d'un état de vibrations qui est obtenue
put veulent envoyer un autre ordinateur
et est en fait ces métis et ses
techniques de téléportation là c'est ce
qu'on utilise pour faire des protocoles
pour transporter l'information à longue
portée lui et c'est extrêmement
pertinent pour justement créé un jour un
réseau par exemple d'internet quand sexy
six mois la somme aurait là un
ordinateur contienne un petit chat vocal
de laval université de cambridge en
angleterre puis on veut tous ceux liés
dans un même réseau mais il faut
transférer pas juste les formations
classiques des européens mais pour canal
de transformer un état il livrait son
plan voyons donc si ce qu'on parle quand
on parle de téléportation mécanique
quantique s'éprend rené tokoin l'état de
cette vibration compte icloud peu
importe l'objet minuscule et le
transférer en longue distance justement
pour ces applications et qui sont qui
sont vraiment des applications réelles
si des droites des besoins réels utile
ici quand on parle de téléportation d'un
objet on rentre plus dans le domaine de
la science-fiction prendre un objet puis
le
ferait apparaître plus loin on est
vraiment dans un autre c'est pas quelque
chose qui s'éternise
la probabilité que ceux ci c'est
tellement petit
une incompréhension mieux pas peur moi
j'ai commencé ce jeudi macroscopique ces
dix élèves n 3 1 puis 23 0 après a tant
réussi reprocher cateau en même temps
qui peut te faire des rentes c'est ce
que j'avais lu jean marie de koninck qui
est un
problème mais cherchera une force navale
il y avait sorti un livre sur comme les
comment les statistiques peuvent être
démesuré puis exprimé que pour une
téléportation et dont il y avait autant
de chances qu'ils ont réussi la
téléportation je pense que peut-être que
je me trompe le mille avec quelque chose
de fou de mainz on nota chances de
réussir la téléportation que de gagner à
la loterie à chaque or jusqu'à
l'extinction du soleil
c'est pas le surprenant parce que c'est
10 à l'a23 ton était une chance serait
sur 16 millions de gagner à la loterie
dix millions dix millions c'est 10 à
l'assiette pour te rendre de salaise de
salah 23 communes foot comme une des
salles à cette foutue m il faut pas
mettre un paquet
pourquoi 10 à l'a23 220 trop ça fait
deux fois qu'on sort pour l'eshop il
humain c'est
comme ça c'est le nombre pic qu'un
objets macroscopiques d'un camp pourquoi
dix élèves n 3 c'est pas une constante
fondamentale en ce sens s'il vient du
fait qu'on ait de cette taille là aussi
mais ça vient c'est quoi enfin
définition exacte comme en passant les
physiques dans son arc les êtres humains
compte la bière en paquet douce et
contre les atomes un paquet de 10 à la
vente tant
que c'est comme ça 6.0 des parties la n3
c'était sa façade à des traits lance
quelque chose comment un gars un gramme
de matière ou bien précis va voir 6.0
départ de saleh 23 at on donc
ça veut juste dire que chaque à ton
extrêmement léger par rapport au
xalatan
c'est que chaque atome sa masse on les
connaît pas ce qu'on peut mesurer la
masse des atomes et différentes
expériences si on lui lance quelque
chose
ce programme par la masse de chaque
attendons que cette carbone mine de
crayon sur la division qui fait beau
c'est la 23 à temps que ça prend pour
faire ma mine de crayon
c'est un chiffre
très gros chiffre ya immensément
d'attendre pour ceux qui comme le reste
du voyage à salers conti cité des grands
ensembles delon espère continuer notre
garde de proches que ce gars est nul
pour l'attendre puisqu'il y en a
tellement qu'on veut pas la guerre n ud
hérité mais le style tellement
janvier à la question d'interprétation
est ce qui est expliqué par rapport à
deux ordinateurs qui pourrait
communiquer de manière
critique esquisses
j'ai déjà entendu parler du terme
clinton intego c'est ça c'est très
important parce qu'on peut parler de son
obsession de glisse bien fait là on va
chez qui
c'est je me suis essayé il explique
c'est que deux particules peuvent être
comme l'île de man a
dit que si une
tourner dans un sens l'autre tondar où
il exerçait maintenant si on voit
qu'elle tourne dans ce sens le site o
matic manque l'autoroute boutonnat autre
genre
c'est y pas mal assez assez c'est quand
on dit que la télé fait la physique est
contre la mécanique quantique c'est un
peu la mécanique des ondes c'est vrai
jusqu'à un certain point mais c'est
disons un peu spécial je te mâcon les
mesures et ces fonds
c'est pas normal avec une normale mais
aussi tu prends deux ans
que te générer de façon systématique
dans un même processus par exemple j'ai
quelque chose qui est qui qui qui sait
ni excès nil qui crée deux particules
voyez ils sont issus du même au delà de
la même même processeur exemples
concrets philippe danton avoir avancé
des fautes ont créé des peurs de
fonniers ont créé des parts de fautes on
envoie un photon qui est une énergie de
xp divise en deux fois donc une énergie
etc sur de l'énergie conserver mais on a
créé deux photons par un processeur on a
deux photons ils sont issus du même
produit donc nécessairement les frères
exactement des frères et donc
nécessairement sillonnant comme tu
disais qu'il ya certaines propriétés
d'autres d'avoir souvent des propriétés
miroir pour qu'on puisse conserver
propriété de ce crime odieux rien ne se
perd rien ne se crée c'est bon pour
l'énergie mais c'est bien pour que c'est
bon pour plein de choses dessus
et saison de l'an fait elles vont et
étriquée ces deux objets là vont être
intrigué et quand on agit sur le on est
les six il faut pas les voir comme deux
objets distincts ses rangs un seul objet
qui n'écrit pas un seul état global on
dit souvent que la mécanique quantique
et non le cadre parce qu'elle est pas
défini
1.6 10.6 passeriez ailleurs comme si
j'agis sur mon bac je laisse tomber mon
verre celui de william peel et votre bon
port vont pas tomber également en
mécanique quantique ont créé ces objets
là il reste lié leur fonction là
rétorque global c'est pas un état qui
est local c'est l'état qui est des
locaux qui souhaitent des à des
milliards de kilomètres les deux s'ils
sont observés en deçà des afic l'autre
mais présentement les gens commencent à
le faire de plus en plus loin des gens
qui ont moi j'ai mon électrons dans mon
cristal il ya pas besoin des gens aux
pays bas qui avaient sur un campus le un
bout du campus on met dans un frigo très
très froid un électron en cadets le
contrôle et on en a un autre dans un
frigo à l'autre bout du campus 1.3 kg
mathieu me rappelle bien de distance et
là on essaie de les délices de l'ailé de
les synchroniser avec des pulls et
monnaies il parle en ce sens mais
deviennent des frères comme s'ils
disaient et ils y sont intriqués d'une
certaine façon 1.3 et pourrait être
aussi aussi loin qu'on peut jusqu'à
demander sa main de plus en plus dur
effectivement puis ce
sac aux problèmes sont veut parce qu'on
se dit mais c'est comme ci communiquent
mais commune et plus vite que la vitesse
de la lumière on fait bien ça se peut
mais c'est toujours cette idée que quand
on dit qu'ils communiquent plus vite que
la lumière ça sous-entend cannes 1 qui
est un endroit qui local pilotes et à
notre endroit qui est aussi local puis
qui leur parle à l'aude
au travers de l'espace mais quand on se
dit pas non non cette perle c'est un
objet global donc quand je parle à un je
parle aux deux simultanément
cette idée qu'on communique de
l'information pas
c'est pas la communication c'est juste
qu'en parlant lui si j'en mesure 1 puis
j'ai fait effondrer l'hôte du sivos
photo automatiquement mais c'est pas
c'est pas parce que l'eau n'était pas
mon ami s'est effondré c'est à mon tour
aussi j'ai un mac à caen 1-0 où tout
s'effondre parce que c'est une fois je
sais aussi qu'il se dit peut pas
transmettre d'informations avec ça parce
que initialement à mesure de ses passes
ton premier électrons va être comme ça
ou encore à moitié c'est pas ça va être
long rouleau
le film the oc aura l'autre qui
parfaitement être effectué en ti au vin
de riz transmis avec ce
que si rien n'avance encaissant ce qui
serait le tibouren en cas d un message
ouais c est idiot qui moi je veux aura
réservé en tirèrent c'est un jeu créé un
message dans le jeu mesure aura une
loterie anti horaire il écrit sans son
big three fait
ça mais là tu ne sais pas quand on a
mesuré de 50% de chances d'avoir horreur
ou anti horreur fait que c'est l'aspect
aléatoire quantique donc qui pourrait
communiquer aux firmes s'équipent pas de
paradoxe était en jeu thain et inquiet
pour ça parce que là c'est in fine sa
théorie sécurié de communication
formation qui se propage plus vite que
la tisza lumière la lumière et se
propage très vite d'une vitesse finit
quand même c'est trois fois dix à la 80e
second qui fait 3 puis 8 0 après un
match contre est rapide mais c'est quand
même fini qu'une vitesse ça vient pas
contredire ça parce qu'il ya aucune
information que tu peux transmettre son
collègue
grec un objet globale qui oui si c'est
prendre à l'endroit et s'effondra
l'autre endroit au 6 mai mais c'est pas
le premier cas causés
s'il vend des objets qui sont faites à
mesure causé l'effondrement
ce qui est paradoxal c'est qu'une mesure
d'une partie du système affecte les
toits c'est fou même en 1.3 kg m non
mais même à même à 100 millions de kilos
maintenant c'est sûrement préféré qu'ils
ont fait c'est fou oui c'est fou puis
les créations c'est les gens disent
c'est une propriété les plus importantes
et les plus folles justement la physique
ont attiré les plus distinctes et puis
les a pas d'équivalent les liaisons de
comportement du bateau ont des
équivalents on parle de coeur de guitare
depuis tantôt mais quand on commence à
parler de ça ça depuis d'équipement et
ça nous paraît logique nous paraît fou
parce que c'est pas quelque chose depuis
qu'on est né depuis que chacun des êtres
humains quittent marché sur sept ans et
demi il n'a jamais expérimenté dans
cette vie cet effet là parce que ça se
passe pas dans le sport
le plus proche de l'expérience humaine
c'est aider les histoires qu'on entend
de jumeaux très très très proches qui
ont été séparés quand je fais mal lotis
sans une douleur ce qui comme
incompréhensible bourg pour lui même
pour tout le monde ça je pensais pas
compris en fait si c'est vraiment vrai
je ne commencerai pas sur cnn c'est
l'image reste là dessus ça m'est arrivé
le temps ce que si d'un compatriote ans
qui mesurait que moi quand surgit un
mendiant on est capable d'aller avec
tant d'incertitudes sur les données
classées 7e de secourir vous à part à
deux scientifiques ou est ce que je
tombe
l'intrication ça l'art abstrait ce
palais est vraiment réel peut-être c'est
pas utile mais finalement à
l'intrication ce qui est drôle c'est que
c'est une ressource pour faire des
calculs commencé qu'avec pour le redis
c'est comme son jus un peu dans les tri
nations il ya paul accélération
exponentielle le redis coincé que par
rapport aux ordis habituelle qu'ils sont
politiques et des 0 et des 1 que paul ii
quand j'étais embêté il se passe les
autres les autres le savent pas là on
dissout et ils les 4 ferries
d'intrication c'est une ressource non
seulement ça existe ça des t-shirts
y ait des gens qui veulent plus
ça servirait des gens qui veulent
cultiver l'intrication qui veulent
augmenter l'intrication pour l'utiliser
c'est pas une blague c'est vraiment une
ressource que si moi j'ai un ordinateur
quantique avec 10 qui dit tout en un
autre avec disques bits mais vaincu
baisser beaucoup plus beaucoup c'est ça
si non linéaire la puissance de quelques
donc si on est ric nos deux ordinateurs
jusqu'au mans disais tout à l'heure ben
justement va avoir un ordinateur avait
cupides et donc laisser seul but c'est
de pouvoir avoir plusieurs centres dont
chacun aura pu faire du calcul qui est
distribué
à travers le monde pour avoir des
ressources qui sont décuplées sont
exponentielles sont exponentielles c'est
vraiment une ressource
lorsque j'ai pas besoin de fabriquer un
ordinateur dans un gros frigo qui fait
mille cubes et peut en avoir plus jamais
il faut ensuite il faut qu'ils soient
capables
c'est ça c'est ça
qu'on dit mesurer c'est ça le gros
problème de toutes ces techniques ont
dit mesurer en assumant un présent c'est
nous qui ont mesuré mais ça se peut que
l'environnement mesure parce que si il
ya des fluctuations pixi figuration
influence même mais mais mais mais mais
mais petits objets mais toutes sont pas
automatiquement ils peuvent s'effondrer
parce qu'ils ont l'impression d'être
mesurés par mais ils sont affectés dont
qui sont une certaine façon mesurée le
gros problème c'est pour ça qu'on allait
maintenant des hommes dans des landes et
dans les frigos très très très froid ce
propos qu'est cgt agitation là pour pas
que l'environnement est une mesure
néfaste sur cet objet l'opic brise tout
d'un coup net l'intrication passer son
affiliation très frais j'essaie monogame
comment fait que disons que fait les
paiements liés qu'on met bien impliqués
ensemble puis moi je m'envoie ailleurs
je prends le métro venant vauban je
rencontre d'autres personnes je m le jeu
permettra gassion un film à voir en
application aux fortes avec philippe de
nouvelles personnes fait que je prends
mes de qubits sont intriqués j'aimais
loin mais là le deuxième but il rentre
un peu notre rugby soit dans la paroisse
dans un monde dans la literie qu'avait
quoi le père d'une intrigue à son
économie donc si fragile comme cela
qu'est né monaghan faut faire attention
pas se mettre dans un environnement
toujours trop dans la même écurie
il faut pas aller la musique des îles
isolées avec toi tu baises
avant que le salut les gars vous êtes
venu préparer puis c'est très cool
est-ce que vous avez des choses qu'on ne
peut pas aborder que vous pensez que nos
auditeurs
doivent savoir devrait savoir des choses
moi je vous dirai pas que les gens
prennent conscience que quand on regarde
de façon très très très très
microscopiques bien sûr si on n'a pas
des petits grains on se retrouve avec
des ondes que ses propriétés de saison
de là mais elles ont des conséquences
qu'on le supraconductivité
physique nucléaire mais aussi ses des
ressources pour fabriquer de nouveaux
dispositifs je pense que c'est assez
c'est assez c'est démystifier certaines
idées comme on parle souvent du chat de
schrödinger qui peut être morts et
vivants et on se dit bon on peut juste
pas comprendre parce que c'est pas mais
on peut comprendre d'une certaine façon
parce que la part du moment où les
objets sont quand même un comportement
dilatoire pis c'est pas fou de se dire
que une onde je peux faire du sopi et
j'obtiens rien simultanément bleus doute
un petit peu moins fort que le riz par
exemple le sont présentement est ce qui
va être une note où il va de notre
simultanément
c'est ici plus fous nécessairement
doivent de penser comme ça c'est
vraiment important de dire que quand on
quand on a des objets microscopiques qui
se comporte de plus en plus comme des
petits dons une fois qu'on a qu'on
commence à aborder ça je pense que ça
démystifie beaucoup de
concepts qui sont sinon ésotérique
autrement parce que
imaginer que les joueurs sont comme ça
puis juste prenez là pour acquis je
posais pas de questions qui on va
continuer comme ça
je pense que pour moi pour moi en tout
cas c'est un message fort et de vous
pendant d'ésotérisme des fois on peut la
physique et quoi entier comme un peu
utilisés ou à mener dans ce genre de
courant
ouais vous pas trop tu es comme site
étions ont parlé au début tu le fait de
mesures est longue des mesures est
l'électron pilote moment qu'on observe
devient une particule
j'aimerais c'est comme des fois repris
comme à ben la conscience humaine ont en
effet soit dans notre environnement si
on envoie des des trucs par la pensée et
s'est montré que des fois c'est comme
tout mélanger ce soit répondez quoi on
répond quoi ces courriels
[Rires]
et quand même quelqu'un qui croit se met
donc expliquer mais qui croît quoi
exactement je comprends ta question que
tu peut affecter l'univers elle mesure 1
à l'observance et ça parce que ces
phénomènes la d'affecter un système
l'observant ces panneaux est celle que
ça se produise moi je vous regarde si
vous changez pas d'être vraiment pris
pour un gay tony cela battre lorrain de
la balle à la même trajectoire que cela
regarde pas c'est vraiment continuer à
observer des objets qui ont une once et
qui rendent par rapport à l'échelle
c'est les électrons consomme à grande
échelle non ça marche pour le phénomène
mais est ce que je dirai à ces gens là
je dirais peut-être se questionner sur
pourquoi est ce qu'ils pensent au pis
quand tu regardes les observations de
son laboratoire tu te rends compte que
phénomène existe pas mais je trouve que
tu es de penser la physique quantique
déjà c'est intéressant que ces gens là
soient curieux mais de ce que ce n'est
plus sur les conséquences qu'on a en
tête c'est pas vrai que le physique
quantique et comme
manifeste partout dans le métro et
toulouse c'est pas comme ça c'est
vraiment souvent citées chez elle picasa
plus grande échelle ce parce que c'est
froid très contrôlé on comprend le monde
différemment mais avec le human dix
nouveaux politiciens ne peut pas
vraiment voir le monde quantique
facilement on peut y penser et faites
moi j'encourage les gens à continuer à y
penser mais de manière plus critique
ses pensées à quelles expériences en
laboratoire qui viderait de la vidéo
points cette idée là aussi c'est vrai
que mon chat me affecté comme l'autre
personne on y pense quand quand feltesse
la réponse est non
fait que j'encourage les gentils lire là
dessus de sources qui sont
validées sortie des scientifiques ou des
gens laissent deux séances qu'écrivent
là dessus dans des magazines des
sciences des livres pour le public c'est
vraiment intéressant qu'il ya une source
russe que les gens se basent sur la
réalité pour faire des énoncés pleut les
gens vont apprendre puis vont peut-être
mieux comprendre les règles d'or en
sciences et dsk il serait possible même
si ce serait très difficile de monter
une expérience qui pourrait prouver que
c'est faux si la réponse est non parce
que si on peut jamais prouvé si souvent
une pente très glissant est ce qu'il
pourrait exister une expérience qui
pourrait prouver que ce que je dis c'est
faux
c'est déjà cela comme la rigole la
réponse est non il n'ya pas d'expérience
qui pourrait le prouver parce que moi ce
que je pense c'est trop et
je sais pas quoi si y'a pas d'expérience
qu'eux et qu'on pourrait imaginer qu'ils
peuvent eux-mêmes
une expérience complètement les
l'imaginaire mais les fondateurs des
mécaniques moitié qu'on disait tout à
l'heure il est impossible d électro n'y
pensons même pas mais imaginons que ce
soit possible on ferait sofres a une
expérience aujourd'hui c'est possible
imaginons que aussi aussi folle soit
elle être un écart de l'imaginer
si oui et on est dans un domaine des
choses qui sont
possibles
pour finir encouragerait les jeunes
oublient part encourager leurs jeunes
peut-être étudié la physique c'est pas
nécessairement c'est comme une finalité
est ma télé fois une cg pour un rct
comme option c'est vraiment un des
joyaux de l'humanité connaît c'est
terrible on comprend le monde de manière
c'est qu'on n'aurait jamais cru possible
avant la précision c'est justesse
incroyable fait que de pouvoir apprendre
ça se ressaisir pour secondaire
un privilège que j'encourage les gens
ouvrir leurs yeux là dessus c'est
surtout les jeunes moi qui se bat tous
les enfants naissent physicien parce que
tous les enfants snes qui regardent
autour d'eux puis ça pourquoi ça
pourquoi si je les ai on a des jeunes
enfants william et moi avait il les deux
disent toujours pourquoi si pourquoi
pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi c'est avec
les temps des fois et qu'on sera
compliqué lesquels les réponses sont
souvent compliquées puis madame blanc
avait répondu mon fils comprend la
physique quantique parce que
les trois tomes physique pour bébé c'est
vrai c'est un rallye pour les enfants
que les collègues et mes collègues écrit
si souvent amazon par exemple wever puis
ça explique la physique quantique
manière pictorial comme pour un enfant
d'un an deux ans puis même comme par le
procureur pour moi mais pour devrait pas
être le même temps les ensacher commence
intéressant que de voir la physique
quantique comme ça ils jamais trop tôt
j'avais trop temps pour penser à ces
questions là puis je pensais en bout de
ligne on peut juste gagner parce qu'on
comprend mieux vaut
faire comment audi d'en parler il ya
beaucoup intéressé s'est beaucoup
impliqué avec la philosophie aussi tu
sais pas ce que c'est
comprendre le monde comprendront bien
mais j'écoutais y avait coûté un
documentaire justement sur qui suivait
un peu les scientifiques au sein tpiy il
ya une madame l'album
officiel qui s'est demandée pour coûter
qu'est ce qui est intéressant c'est que
tu écoutes décidant et la tentative mais
moi je voulais comprendre
intéressés par la philosophie par la
physique et puis je voulais comprendre
le monde je me posais tout est question
l'idée d'où l'on vient et puis a dit je
trouvais que la physique me donner des
réponses plus concrètes et
puis aussi des gens dire est tellement
ddd qu'on disait est tellement d'intérêt
industries et des gens aussi que ça les
intéresse de voir comment ça peut
impacter le monde et on ne rien d'avoir
des impacts majeurs sur sur nos
technologies puis les gens qui sont plus
à l'est un peu moins clair c'est que ça
ma philosophie club et être plus
atteints ont aussi
beaucoup de choses à
s'intéresser
le futur
merci les gars c'était faire un ace
merci régulation
du contenu excellent tu as tout un
podcast convient
oui
si vous voulez plus de contenu excellent
comme ce que vous venez d'entendre aller
sur une pétillante le pétrole vous
abonner pour trop de leur part mais
aussi trop de la mouette trois pièces
par morlaàs par mois ils avaient les
pattes carte en avance acquise avec les
premiers de votre groupe d'amis
à vous écouter les podcasts qu'ils
allaient avoir pouvoir avoir une avance
quand vous allez tirer la dynamique
entre les amis tout le temps avons une
avance sur les jobs en avance ou des
gens tout le toit mais avec pétillante
une avance sur l'humanité complète en
plus en plus parce que le chèque le
podcast su ni voulu nous en jazz et
davantage on fait des encore moins de
filtres à préchac podcast avec là on
vient de finir de tourner le podcast on
va en jaser on va tâcher les nicole non
nicole il est maintenant évident comme
le fils travaille la place de taza
taille est là mais on jase on parle de
conversion qu'on m'aide à voir mais ce
si vous voulez avoir accès
mais heureusement pour nous
malheureusement pour vous s'est excusé
sur pétule il faut s'abonner abonnez
vous